okay
[Music]
all right
so Paul's office is
just always
[Music]
okay
foreign
everybody
so
um
members take your seats we need to get
going
holidays
I mean I think
foreign
members take your seats we need to get
going
thank you
foreign
[Music]
2023 are you ready for the question all
those babies say aye those opposed me
the eyes have it and the house is
adjourned the house will attend to a
Prayer by the member from Manchester
representative Nicole liply second vice
president of board of directors for the
temple Alice yeshuam in Manchester
good morning
reminds us of our Exodus from Egypt and
the beginning of a 40-year trek to the
promised land
the former slaves needed leadership
Innovation and community in order to
make the journey From Slavery to Freedom
our state needs the same gifts
we need talented leaders blessed with
vision who are able to look at
challenges and come up with Creative
Solutions
we need new ways of seeing and solving
our problems both old and new as our
society continues to change grow and
respond to the 21st century
we need each other to move forward
we need to listen to one another and
work together
with those with whom we agree as well as
those with whom we disagree
together for the general good of the
Granite State
our house is made up of talented people
who give of our time to lead who care
deeply about helping New Hampshire face
and overcome difficulties people who
want to join hands together for the
common benefit of the whole community
may we be blessed with patience with
compassion
with the energy to do what needs to be
done and the abilities to work together
productively
may we have the vision and dedication to
serve and Lead our state and together
let us say Amen
the chair recognizes the member from
Litchfield representative Rich lasalles
who will leads an Pledge of Allegiance
foreign
I'll recognize the member of the Lincoln
represent of Jerry Stringham and his
brother Peter of Newcastle who will now
sing our national anthem
oh say can you see by the dawn's early
light what's so proudly we hailed at the
twilight's last gleaming whose brought
stripes and bright stars through the
perilous fight or the ramparts we
watched were so gallantly streaming
bursting in
it gave proof through the night that our
flag was still there oh say does that
Star Spangled
Banner yet
wave or the land of the free
and the home of the bridge
[Applause]
everything
the house will attend to request for
leaves of absence Mr Speaker the day
illness represented unless otherwise
ordered by the house
the house will attend to the
introduction of guests Mr Speaker please
welcome Denise Bolton and Claire Peters
wife and granddaughter of Representative
Bolton Stephanie and Cole Cody guests of
Representative Sheehan Cara Dunn and
Brian Crowley wife and guest of
Representative Dunn Stefan Toth guest of
Representative Malloy Kevin and Counting
osner parents of Representative Lloyd
Mark plamondon Julian Sutcliffe guest of
Representative tolersky John Cole father
of Representative Cole Sanjay gowda
guest of Representative mangaputi and
elementary students from Green Valley
School guests of Representative seaworth
and shuitt there with us in the gallery
today
Welcome to the New Hampshire house
[Applause]
see I recognize the clerk
members will be in their seats
I'm ready
do you recognizes the clerk
Mr Speaker
accompanied by the consul general of
India and New York Mr randhir Jay's wall
the house now welcomes the Indian
ambassador to the United States of
America taranjit Singh Sandhu who will
now address the House of Representatives
thank you
it is an honor to have
the Indian ambassador
Sandu visit us today in the spirit of
diplomacy and friendship
we also welcome general counsel of India
jazzwell
Ambassador Sandu and his distinguished
career spanning more than 30 years in
the Indian Foreign Service started his
diplomatic career in the former Soviet
Union Russia then moved on to a new
Embassy in Ukraine he is one of the most
experienced Indian diplomats in U.S
Affairs and extensive resume includes
service in the Indian mission in
Washington D.C his first secretary at
the embassy of India
work in the permanent mission of India
to the United Nations
Council general of India in Frankfurt
joint secretary United Nations and
administration
officer on special Duty with the
ministry of external affairs
taking his charge as ambassador to the
United States in February of 2020
Ambassador Sandhu has made it his
priority to strengthen our partnership
through extensive Outreach efforts
driven by our shared values I'm looking
forward to forging a successful path
forward with the Ambassador and
continuing the good work that has been
accomplished so far I now want to write
Ambassador Sandu to say a few words
thank you
Speaker of the House
Sherman Packard
Senate President Jeff Bradley
state representatives
senators in attendance
Council General
ladies and gentlemen
namaskar good morning
it is indeed my honor to address this
August House
I bring with me greetings of 1.4 billion
people of India
let me thank the honorable speaker
the elected representatives
and through you
the people of the granite state for this
opportunity
it is indeed a reflection of the respect
that you have for the government and the
people of India
I know New Hampshire is getting busy
with the presidential aspirants flocking
and I'm told that the house schedule was
Advanced today to accommodate my dress
so this occasion is indeed special for
me
and ambassadors are notorious for long
speeches but let me assure you
that I have a finite end
yesterday I had the privilege to tour
this historic building and interact with
the executive and the legislative
leadership of the state
two things were striking to me
first
the weight of history that this location
carries
and second
the Infectious passion that each of you
have to work selflessly for the state
ladies and gentlemen
from New Delhi to New Hampshire
there are several threads that bind us
together
from the world's largest democracy
to the largest State Assembly in the
United States
we are Guided by the same values and the
vision
We the People
as I stand in this Temple of democracy
steeped in people's hopes and
aspirations
I am even more convinced of the strength
of our shared beliefs
our deep rooted friendships and
partnership
we continue to draw inspiration from our
shared Legacy
last year
India celebrated 75 years of its
independence
as one of the earlier state to declare
independence from Great Britain
you would appreciate
that we equally cherish and nourish the
hard one freedom
honorable speaker
knowledge and spirit of inquiry have
always been a constant between India and
the New England region
back in the 18th century
as the bugle of Independence fill the
air in New Hampshire
so did the urge of Scholars to
understand the philosophy of India
soon along with trade and merchandise
from India a cargo of knowledge and
ancient text
arrived on the shows of Portsmouth
the traffic in Reverse was equally
impressive
Travelers and Scholars from New England
Mark Twain and John Higgins headed east
and reaching our mutual engagement
fast forward to the present day
Indian students comprise the largest
cohort of international scholars in the
United States
and of those many choose universities
and institutions in New Hampshire
when our students seek education in
Dartmouth or when a scholar from South
New Hampshire University pursues
Fulbright scholarship in India we create
a lasting friendship between our peoples
ladies and gentlemen
India United States ties be it in the
field of Defense renewable energy
Education Health Technology Innovation
or startups
our gathering stream and strength thanks
also to the entrepreneurs in Concord
Manchester and Nashua
the Indian Pharma industry accounts for
the supply of 40 percent of all generic
medicines in the United States
solar energy projects ways to wealth
Innovations and circular economy models
are bringing new actors in the India New
Hampshire space
I am told that New Hampshire was the
first state in the United States to
introduce LED traffic lights
I'm happy to share with you today that
India runs the world's largest zero
subsidy domestic lighting program
affordable LED for all ujjala
we both believe in bringing light to the
world and that too efficiently
New Hampshire sent the first American to
space
as a space-faring nation India is proud
of its missions to moon and Mars today
NASA is collaborating with our space
research organization ISRO on a
synthetic aperture radar that can help
monitor climate change
NASA will soon train our next astronaut
honorable speaker and representatives
our leaders
President Biden and Prime Minister Modi
characterize India U.S ties as
partnership for Global good
or people call it the most defining
relationship of 21st century
our partnership within the quad ipef and
i2u2 Frameworks is creating progress and
prosperity for the World At Large
as trusted Global Partners we are
working to address pressing challenges
of our times
how do we deraze the global supply chain
how do we navigate the world of critical
and emerging Technologies
how do we effectively respond to climate
change
how do we grapple with terrorism and
threats from the Cyber domain
how do we deal with health security and
Future pandemics
these solutions to complex questions
would involve combining American
Technology with Indian talent and the
U.S Trend to innovate and India's
ability to scale
the good news is that some of this is
already happening
American companies are manufacturing
more in India than before
India and the United States have
launched a historic initiative on
critical and emerging Technologies
the technologies that are driving
Tomorrow's World yesterday
semiconductors artificial intelligence
Telecom and quantum
we have active vaccine and Medicine
collaborations such as the corbavax that
are more affordable and accessible
our partnership is not just for the
well-being of our peoples but for the
global good
the Indian diaspora has been a vibrant
and strong Bridge connecting our two
great Nations
let me give you just one example
the Britain wood twins IMF and World
Bank were born here in New Hampshire at
the Mount Washington hotel and here we
are
when the World Bank is soon going to
have
beheaded by a proud Indian American
and the number two in IMF is already an
Indian American
honorable speaker and members
the massive transformation underway in
India politically socially and
economically is an important enabler in
deepening India's ties with the United
States
today India has the second woman
president in our independent history she
is also the first Who belongs to the
indigenous community
it is not just a glass ceiling which is
broken
it is a reflection of what father of my
nation Mahatma Gandhi said my life is my
message
India stands today as a beacon of
stability amidst geopolitical
uncertainties and Usher of global
economic growth a solution provider to
some of the more complex challenges of
our times and a consensus builder in
times of conflict and Rising tensions
India remains interesting important and
incredible
be it the world's largest biometric
program aadhar or world's largest
financial inclusion program jandan
yojana or world's largest Health
protection Mission Bharat
India has actively used technology as a
tool for good governance
today 40 percent of world's digital
payments come from India
we have more than 80 000 startups out of
which 115 of them are unicorns
are rural internet users
340 million outnumber Urban users
290 million
IMS has forecast 15 percent of global
growth this year would come from India
India is an ancient civilization but a
Young Nation
50 percent of the population that is out
of 1.4 billion people is below 26 years
India's Talent can be a game changer for
Innovation and research for the world
we bring to table our strengths and
successes and we are always ready to
share it with the world from vaccines to
disaster relief
to our digital public goods to our
skills
during the pandemic we supplied vaccines
to over 100 countries when disasters
struck in Turkey we were the first
country to send a humanitarian mission
as India leads G20 this year
with motto of one Earth one family one
future our Approach to Global Good Will
resonate far and wide
honorable speaker and representatives
as Prime Minister Modi said much of the
India that we dream of lies ahead of us
it is only a journey we have started
we look towards our friends like the
United States to join us in our journey
ahead
so no doubt our task is cut out
as the poet laureate from New Hampshire
Robert Frost said
the woods are lovely dark and deep but I
have promises to keep and miles to go
before I sleep and miles to go before I
sleep let us strive and Thrive together
thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you Mr ambassador
we'd like to present this plaque to you
in appreciation for your Outreach
efforts and continued friendship from
the general court of New Hampshire
[Applause]
our Senate colleagues can now leave
unless unless unless you want to stay
here and vote with us
absolutely
the house the house will attend to a
communication
Mr Speaker
in a letter dated April 1st 2023 Mr
Clerk
I regretfully write you this letter
today to notify you of my resignation
from the New Hampshire house on Monday
March 27th I sustained several blunt
force traumas to the head at my job as a
security officer at Dartmouth health and
spent much of the evening in early
morning in the trauma Bay not only have
I sustained a concussion and as a
consequence but neurologists believe
that an aneurysm has developed in a
critical brain artery
further testing is needed and potential
surgery is keeping me out of work but
doctors are recommending that I limit
stress in the meantime
not only that I can feel some wires up
there are loose as since Monday my
emotions have been all over the place
from being able to joke about it to
sobbing within seconds will it seemingly
no through line
the headaches aren't helping as such I
have to step away
it has been an honor to know you over
the years but I must now focus on
ensuring whatever is in my brain yes
there was in fact a brain in there this
entire time does not rupture to my
colleagues in the Democratic caucus
serving as your Deputy floor leader has
been on Parallel Joy carry on the good
work
please share the following with the
Republican floor leader Morty I turned
myself into a civilian again Morty I'm
citizen Rick
I hope that someday I can come join you
again as Frosty the Snowman once said he
waved goodbye saying don't you cry I'll
be back again someday all the best Josh
adjutant
[Applause]
resignation is accepted with regret
I also now attend a consent calendar
Mr Speaker from the committee on finance
House Bill 269 removed by
Representatives Aaron shartlift McCarter
Tom Manion Santo nastasso Pines Granger
papovichi Mueller filial and noddard
from the committee on Ways and Means
House Bill 445 removed by representative
Simon a bear Gerhard Fitzpatrick Carol
McGuire Fred Davis Sirois groda
shirtleff and Santo nasasa
there any other bills removed from
consent calendar
Senator Bosman was a consent calendar
with the relevant amendments as printed
in today's health record be adopted are
you ready for the question all those in
favor say aye those both nay the eyes
have been consent calendar is adopted
house will now attend to the regular
calendar
majority committee on finance to which
was referred house bill to FNA local and
act relative to State fees funds
revenues and expenditures having
considered the same report the same
following Amendment the recommendation
of Bill had a password Amendment Senator
Ken Wyler for the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee
have been considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority Report
with the following resolution resolve
that is inexpedient to legislate
representative Mary Jane walner from the
minority of the committee
the amendment is one two four seven
eight printed in-house record 18 Pages 1
through 82.
chair recognize representative Hall
good morning colleagues
thank you Mr Speaker
the bill before us sets out our plan for
the next two years
the bill before us
can either make us off as a better state
or a worse state
for those that were here
when the budget briefing happened we
were handed a document I hope you guys
read it that's this document for those
who saw it
there are copies in the back that were
left over
this document lays out two important
things about the budget that I want to
highlight
talks about our spending and on page two
in a very nice pie chart it describes
our spending as
3.957 billion dollars
in the general funds
several Pages after that it points out
our revenue for General funds
that's 3.73
billion a shortage of 220 million
dollars
in my household we don't choose to spend
more than we take in because that leads
to things like bankruptcy that's not
good fiscal policy
our state benefited
because we had revenues that were above
projections because we had cut certain
taxes the economy was doing well
the last legislature underestimated
revenues and with all of that we ended
up with a significant balance
approximately 800 million dollars in
additional Revenue
the last legislature and even some of
the bills this year use that in Wise
ways
but it did in fact
we can't count on all of that to prop us
up
our spending needs to be below our
revenues
anything short of that is being fiscally
irresponsible
as a member of Finance
I had a decision to make I could have
voted nay on the on the auto pass motion
I chose not to show up that day and ask
for a substitute
I did that to respect my party
but I did want to point out
that there are in fact
an enormous amount of spending in this
budget it grows
over the last budget 18.2 percent
in terms of new spending
and that is not something that is
fiscally responsible I would ask that
you would oppose the committee Amendment
so that we can bring up another
amendment that puts us in line with the
rate of inflation and population growth
thank you
do you recognize the representative
Weiler
thank you Mr Speaker
we are in a special place
when the governor gives me a proposal I
don't call it the governor's budget I
call it the governor's input
for convenience I label them hp1 and hb2
and then we go and change them because
this is where the budget is created
that's what the Constitution says what
we do is the budget what everybody else
does are changes
so
we have looked at
a comparison now between let me explain
things I just think I heard of why
in this
thing with the pie charts you have head
handed out
there's a difference between
page two
which is
the money that will be appropriated and
spent
and page
five
which is what we expect to take in in
the next two years
so there's a difference of a couple
hundred million
but remember we expect
all our agencies not to spend everything
they should lapse some money
and now that lapse comes into page two
that's the extra 200 million that's why
that's
gives us more money to spend than what
the revenue estimates will be going
forward
so we're very closely divided house
so we believe we put things in this
budget to please both sides
and you'll hear about that in the future
so
we want to expedite the retirement of
the interest interest and dividends tax
and there's also
some big pay increases
now when we compare the budget
2425 to what 2223 passed two years ago
that is a very different comparison to
what the actual spending is from 23
verses 24 25. it is not an 18 increase
from what is presently being spent in
this present biennium because there is
so much hundreds of millions of federal
money in Recovery Act and so on that
have salute this thing so the actual
increase over the the actual adjusted
authorized in this present budget is
more like seven percent
it's still a big increase but look at
what's happened in the last two years
I asked the LBA to compute
the inter the inflation adjustment which
we normally use when we look at a budget
12.7 percent over the two years and then
when we use What's called the tax
expenditure limitation we try not to
exceed the inflation rate for the
previous period plus the population
growth the population growth was one and
a half percent those two figures
together add up to 14.2 percent
that's a big increase that it's hired to
overlook
so when the when the budget came to us
with
actually the input came to us
with a 10 percent increase in 24 and a
two percent increase in 25.
we didn't give an increase in the
previous budget but now that total 12
percent is roughly around the rate of
inflation
that's something you can't Overlook
we're all witnessing it at the gas pump
the grocery store and all our electric
bills and every other Bill we pay
inflation is is not a good thing but
we've got to face it
we've got to work with it thankfully the
revenue has come in well
so we have the money
to cover what is needed even with the
inflation adjustments we have to
understand that it's more than I'd like
to see an increase but
the same thing happens when I fill up my
gas tank I go to the grocery stores
it's not an increase I'd like to see but
it's reality we have to face reality and
adjust to it
so
the budget has a lot of things that are
different now the reason we talk about
hp2 before we talk about hb1 because in
that same Constitution it says hb1 can
only contain the spreadsheets in effect
the numbers that go with all the
agencies we have if you've looked at the
thousand plus pages that go in a hb1
each one is a spreadsheet for an agency
or part of an agency
and so
if there's any change that takes place
as I say we passed 50 bills out of this
house
that are mostly included in the in the
budget and that added 165 million which
we've endeavored to include in the
budget that we passed so that money is
there that helped to increase the budget
but
we have to adjust to all these things as
we do
and those are the realities so we're
giving a pay increase we're taking care
of a problem from 2011 with mainly
affected group two
that's going to be an expensive fix
we're giving cost of living increase
those are things that are all pressured
by inflation
so I ask for your patience and
understanding that we have a bill that
hp2 needs to pass because it contains
the enabling legislation so if there's
any change in an organization of a
department or
people leaving people gaining new
equipment new
a lot of a lot of money spent on
information technology so all that has
to be
written about in hp2 So it explains what
the spreadsheets contain and why all
those figures are there and mostly when
you look at hb2 hb1 it shows previous
year spending and then current
projection and there will be a
difference based upon many of those
bills we passed and many of the facts
that have come before us every virtually
every agency has said to us we can't
hire people we're losing people we're
short people we have all these vacancies
in some ways those vacancies help us to
fund the pay increase
but they also make the dealing a little
bit harder for some of the agencies and
we'll hear about it when people come to
us and say why do I have to wait so long
in line to get my registration for my
car
because they're short people
that's happening and almost every agency
will deal with let's hope this budget
will help to mend it so I ask for your
support and those things that seem out
of line with history because we need to
do that and another thing that I've been
questioned on was
I was fortunate to be here in 1999 when
we created the education trust fund and
created what we considered adequacy and
funded it
and education trust fund was only there
to fund adequacy and we actually kept it
a little bit below what we needed
because if it went over that froze money
we couldn't spend elsewhere
so we had to adjust
the education trust fund it had gone a
while without being adjusted last budget
we took 100 million
out of the swept fund because it was
producing so much money
we're back down about a third of the
enrollment from 20 years ago
so you can't keep expecting to spend
more money on fewer people
meanwhile Medicaid is growing like crazy
so there has to be a shift from some of
the funds still we spent more on
education than we have in the past so
I've adjusted the
the education trust fund so we don't tie
up money that we would need somewhere
else because the education trust fund
takes a piece a big piece of the general
fund we need that money in the general
fund because sometimes we add it to the
Fish and Game fund sometimes we add it
to the highway fund depending on how bad
the weather is every year
so hp2 this amendment before you
if you are supporting any further
Amendment you've got to vote for this
otherwise those further amendments are
meaningless they'll be referring to a
section that no longer exists
so hb2
committee Amendment must be passed
you understand why because all the rest
of it is meaningless if we don't I thank
you for your attention as a member of
yield the questions
one
remember yields the one
thank you Mr Speaker and thank you Mr
chairman for taking my question is it
correct that this budget presented to us
by the finance committee is balanced
that it contains no new taxes and fees
and that it in fact contains a small tax
cut as well
those are excellent points
remember the answer is yes there's a
mobile defer the question yes
thank you Mr Speaker and thank you Mr
chairman for the follow-up is it not
also correct that much of what is
referred to as spending in this budget
is in fact paying down debt as well as
paying for large capital projects that
would normally be included in the
capital budget and is in fact saving
future taxpayers from more taxes
very well well put and I totally agree
thank you
representative Hall has requested a
division vote
members take your seats
[Music]
make sure everybody turns the voting
stations on
foreign
this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button of your pose will press the
red button voting stations are open for
30 seconds
[Music]
represent Wendy Thomas
representative Wendy Thomas
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote household Tennessee
to vote
351 voting yay 38 voting nay the
amendment is adopted
bill was on second reading now open to
further Amendment
I was born in representative Osborne The
Wilhelm offer floor Amendment 1336.
the chair recognizes representative
Osborne
thank you Mr Speaker
so first of all I want to thank the
finance committee for all of their hard
work over the last several weeks I know
I can speak for most of us here that you
couldn't probably pay me enough to do
what they do for free and we thank them
for their service and I hope they don't
look too kindly on uh or unkindly on
those of us who are now going to jump in
at the end of the fourth quarter and try
to run a few plays before the clock Runs
Out
um I took the opportunity yesterday to
sit down with my friend from Manchester
to hammer out a few things that that we
think will help smooth our way to uh to
a widespread yes vote on the uh ought to
pass as amended uh later on today
and maybe we'll uh induce some more
withdrawals of some floor amendments
that are that are still hanging out
there
uh just real quickly uh to point out a
few of the things that are contained
within this amendment
um
it was brought to my attention that we
had put some language into hb2 regarding
the efas that had passed on the house
floor that were sponsored by Republicans
and that there were some other EFA bills
sponsored by democrats that did not make
their way into hb2 and I just uh that
didn't sit right with me and it seems
unfair and I'm sure my friend from
Manchester agreed with that so we uh we
agreed to pull that out of hb2
and uh my friend was also kind enough to
allow us to put in to hb2 by this
amendment the language from HB 127 uh
reforming uh the the state of emergency
procedures
real estate which we have passed in this
house a few times at this point so I I
appreciate my friend for uh for agreeing
to do that with me there's also a few
spending items that we added in there
that I think will uh will help smooth
things along today and there is a larger
item that I'm going to ask of the
education committee to speak about
having to do with adequacy funding this
was uh exactly the same as an amendment
that was going to be brought forth by uh
rep the leadership from the education
committee as well as the leadership from
division two of finance and they all
agree that this is the way that we
should be going
I think most of us will be agreeable to
what they're proposing
and uh so I'll turn it over to other
people to talk about that so thank you
Geo recognize Works in Wilhelm
thank you Mr Speaker
from the beginning of this process house
Democrats have been working hard to
build a fair budget that delivers for
all Granite Staters
building on the very good elements in
the committee Amendment including pay
raises for our state employees and
retirement benefits for our police and
firefighters I'm pleased to stand before
you in support of this bipartisan floor
Amendment which I've co-sponsored with
my good friend
know my great friend from Auburn
doing everything we can to pass a budget
today
this amendment does so much to improve
the budget and deliver on key policy
priorities including affordable housing
public education and health care which
are all important to New Hampshire
families as well as New Hampshire
employers
let's start first with housing it's no
secret that New Hampshire is in an
affordable housing crisis New
Hampshire's unhoused population is
spiking and rent is continuing to rise
just this winter Mayors across the state
wrote to the governor expressing an
urgent need for more concerted support
for warming centers and shelters
New Hampshire needs housing that our
Workforce our families and our seniors
can afford New Hampshire housing
estimates that we need 20 000 more
housing units and that number will
continue to grow in the coming years
rents have risen by over 30 percent in
the last five years alone and Home
Ownership is Out Of Reach for many
emergency housing assistance for
individuals expired in March and a
recent report shows that rent is rising
in New Hampshire faster than in most
States
we need more funding for affordable
housing not less which is why I'm
pleased that this bipartisan Amendment
restores 15 million to the affordable
housing fund
second is public education
this bipartisan Amendment maintains the
status quo for the education Freedom
account eligibility limits participation
to families at 300 percent of federal
poverty
it also brings down the line item for
vouchers from 60 million to 40 million
over the biennium freeing up funds to
reinvest in our Public Schools
Additionally the amendment includes
bipartisan lab luno school funding
formula which more adequately and
equitably supports our Public Schools
especially in communities like Berlin
and Claremont that need it the most
third is health care right now hospitals
and community health centers are
struggling to care for granted Staters
because of Staffing and funding issues
pleased that this bipartisan amendment
makes impactful and data-driven
investments in our state's Health Care
System providing preventative physical
and mental health care is an important
way to keep patients out of our
hospitals
this bipartisan amendment invests five
million dollars in system of care and
two million dollars in the Family
Resource Centers helping to better meet
the health care needs of our
constituents in their own homes and in
their own communities
additionally Community Mental Health
leaders have made it clear if the
Medicaid reimbursement rate does not
increase over the next few years
psychiatric patients will continue to
suffer long wait times and low care
availability
this bipartisan Amendment invests an
additional 40 million dollars to boost
Medicaid provider rates which will help
address our state's ability to attract
and retain the workforce that it needs
for our health care System
Mr Speaker we need a budget that
reflects our priorities as a state and
that is fair to everyone
the bipartisan amendment makes critical
Investments to address our Statewide
housing crisis brings balance to our
public education system and delivers
community-based Health Care Solutions to
thousands of granite Staters by
bolstering its Workforce
it's also a testament to the fact that
when we come together in good faith and
we listen to one another we disagree
without being disagreeable and find
common ground and compromise where we
can Republicans win Democrats win
but most importantly Granite Staters win
because when we are able to deliver
results on education housing and health
care
those are the reasons that our
constituents sent us here and it's
exactly what this bipartisan budget
amendment does that's why I'm urging my
colleagues on both sides of the aisle to
vote Yes on this amendment so we can get
closer to delivering on a budget that
works for all Granite Staters thank you
Mr Speaker
Geo recognize representative Vlad
thank you Mr Speaker
and I'd like to thank the bipartisan
group I had the opportunity to work with
in trying to craft legislation
that would best meet the needs of our
students throughout this state and so
thank you to the representative from
Merrimack
Hillsboro
Grafton County where I come from
in Rockingham the four of you including
myself I think did a remarkable job in
in trying to support our children
there is a handout which was in the back
the room in the ante room and most of
you might have at this point in time
which reflects the proposal from our
governor and the proposal that came out
of Finance for hb2 and then a Amendment
which we're speaking about right now
1285 H which has been incorporated into
the amendment on the screen behind me
that is the floor amendment in which we
worked diligently over a number of days
and weeks in fact this goes right back
over years when I first came into this
house in 2008
when I looked at the Joint legislative
oversight group that costed out an
adequate education then in 2018
the formula that came out of that
education study committee and then in
2020 the commission report they all had
some common
areas which we can come to agree on one
of those areas is yes we have to look at
the amount of funding we're providing
education but even just as important and
perhaps even more important how we
distribute those funds to various
communities and municipalities
on the spreadsheet you see there's 245
municipalities identified and you can
walk across and see how those monies are
allocated out
the formula which came out of the
finance committee and that which you see
in 1285 which is part of the amendment
on the screen behind you are almost
identical in the revenues needed to make
it work
but the difference is that in the
formula that's on the board now and came
from that group of four that met
we looked at base cost of adequacy and
the base cost is on the left hand side
of the formula the side of the formula
that every student every municipality in
the state receives that amount of money
per pupil
every time we increase Base adequacy by
one hundred dollars that requires 16
million dollars in Appropriations to
support
when I learned that the formula that was
being presented earlier where we're
upping the Annie from thirty nine
hundred dollars to four thousand seven
hundred dollars
that would have upped the Annie on the
left-hand side by 128 million dollars
is that where we need to be putting our
adequacy money now Two Towns which
receive perhaps in sweat money more
money than is necessary to cost out an
adequate education
or should we be planning that money and
distributing to towns
that need this because of a number of
costing efficiencies
operational efficiencies unique
characteristics those municipalities
that was watching the budget in under
fiscal capacity disparity Aid in 2008 we
took it out in 2011. we've discussed it
in 2018 and 2020
this is what we have now coming back
into our budget where we're taking the
monies and distributing it to the towns
the property poor towns that need that
support you will also notice in this
amendment
notes our community loses money the
majority of communities that need this
Revenue are receiving it and that's well
over approximately 185 communities out
of the 245.
secondly we looked at in this
Amendment the need to support our
Charter Public Schools as well
and our goal was of course Charter
Public Schools are funded now on the
base amount that's the 3 900 in this
bill it's 40 40 4 000 dollars
differentiated eight is added into that
excluding the special education so that
brings with the extra five thousand
dollars charter schools now will be
receiving per pupil nine thousand
dollars plus those amounts in
differentiated Aid that that child will
bring excluding special education
so our goal is not to have a broken
formula where stabilization
is there because we're not doing what we
should be doing on the left-hand side or
even on the granting side we're now
allocating our resources to best support
our children in the state so I ask all
here today this is a bipartisan
Amendment that's part of the amendment
on the board and back please support
this legislation it's imperative we get
the support out and take that first step
forward to addressing these needs we
have in terms of educating students
throughout New Hampshire thank you
General product asked for roll calls
that's efficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote
foreign
Wilhelm floor Amendment 1336
this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button of your opposed or press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
wall members president an opportunity to
vote household 10 save the vote
326 voting a 63 voting a
the amendment is adopted
bill is on second reading open to
further Amendment
representative string of Moon's floor
Amendment 1290
chair recognizes representative
Stringham
thank you Mr Speaker
I am here to speak on behalf of this
amendment which preserves two years of
the interest and dividends reductions
but does not accelerate future cuts to
the biennium which would be harmful to
the state
a little bit about the IND tax the IND
tax is scheduled to be eliminated by
2027 in current law through a bill
passed in 2021.
the IND tax is mostly paid by the
wealthiest granted Staters only 14
percent of granite stateers pay any IND
tax and more than half of the revenue
comes from people receiving two hundred
thousand dollars or more in interest in
dividend income
under our constitution every person is
meant to share in paying the cost of
government as they are able and we are
proposing
uh
in the budget we just passed to
eliminate the only tax that makes our
wealthiest citizen share in that burden
the interest in dividends tax is our
fifth largest tax Moody's has been
giving us favorable ratings despite our
Decades of budget Cliffhangers partly
because of our Diversified tax system
which helps us survive major crisis
in the past hb2 Amendment this tax would
be eliminated entirely in this biennium
by 2025.
those that are in support of
accelerating the IND phase out indicate
that the impact is 17.4 million in this
budget but almost all the revenue impact
will show up only in the following
biennium 2627 and it'll be substantial
well not part of the legislature when
the phase out was passed I heard some of
the debates
proponents
of the phase out
say there was warranted so that we could
see what our needs are in the future
with our future budgets
how the economy responds to the cuts and
make adjustments is necessary
and now we hear both the governors and
the ways and means expect flat revenues
and Rising costs with inflation for
needed services
a phase out is originally sponsored
would provide us with the opportunity to
react to the impacts of the change in
our ability to fund the necessary
government functions
our our finance share often said we have
to consider what financial needs we have
to address if circumstances change flat
revenues inflation put considerable
pressure on the budget process this year
and be even more so in the next biennium
some of my colleagues state that the IND
tax is the best tax to cut that is the
most harmful to economic activity
warranting even faster reduction I
disagree with that when I arrived in
Concord for this term it seemed almost
unanimous that the three highest
priorities to promote economic growth
and opportunity for granted State
Staters our Workforce expansion
addressing housing shortages and
enhancing education funding for low
property value towns neither the
reduction of or in particular the
hyper-accelerated elimination of the
state's interest in dividends tax do
that
if you want to generate more housing
it's important to cut the taxes on
housing which is property taxes my
colleagues are fond of saying that when
you tax something you get less of it the
taxes granted Staters and our businesses
pay are predominantly property taxes
like no other state in the country
so I would maintain our if effort to
reduce Granite State taxes should focus
on property which is the real
Battleground for promoting growth
accelerating the reduction in the IND
tax will not be helpful for that
look the IND tax phase out has begun
this amendment still keeps gigantic
decreases in the IND tax as planned when
passed implementing two years of
substantial cuts
with the an elevated risk of recession
in the in the coming years and the
potential rise for needed Services
driven by inflation public resources
must be conserved
please let's just take the win
please vote green which preserves the
two-year phase out of the Indy tax in
this biennium but not the total
elimination of the tax and this
important source of Revenue and general
funds in this biennium
uh thank you very much and I'd like a
division vote gear recognize this
president of genetium
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker what are the advantages of
phasing out the IND tax sooner than
later
there are many
first New Hampshire will actually be
able to say it's an income tax-free
state
second many think the amendment will
restore 35 to 40 million tax dollars
over the coming biennium however that's
when we think about this statically we
need to think about this tax dynamically
for example what are the some of the
dynamic elements number one it's going
to stop the migration of wealthy New
Hampshire retirees to States like
Florida where Florida does not have an
income tax and they don't have an
interest in dividends tax
we'll encourage the migration of people
from heavily taxed states like New York
California and Massachusetts to come
here and what's the advantage to that
well first of all let's be clear do
wealthy people stuff their mattresses
with cash
for the most part no right what are they
doing with it they're they're putting
money in Banks
they're they're making Investments they
are
investing in building and production
and they themselves are buying goods and
services
if that person moves to a state like
Florida
they're not going to invest in New
Hampshire
but if that person is in New Hampshire
that must much more likely to invest in
New Hampshire businesses and in New
Hampshire in general
The increased Savings in in banks will
help people get the more money there is
for loans possibly the better the loan
rates more Builders can can get money
more easily as well
there's also a fairness issue
the interest in dividends tax is more
likely to hit the elderly and retired
so why should they be burdened why
should they be burdened with the income
tax that we have right now in New
Hampshire let's get rid of it sooner
than later time is of the essence please
press the red button to stop this
amendment and make sure New Hampshire is
truly income tax free sooner than later
thank you chair recognizes
representative Dan McGuire
thank you Mr Speaker
the interest in as as the first Speaker
said I think that the interest in
dividends tax is the worst tax that we
have why it's a tax on savings and
investment
savings is something we need more of not
less of and in fact we spend money to
try to encourage savings we we try to
encourage building of housing we try to
encourage business we try to encourage
economic activity by spending money but
by taxing savings and taxing
accumulation of capital we are hurting
the future we are hurting the things
that grow
buildings Capital
businesses in New Hampshire and
therefore future tax revenue
I tried to think of a simple way of
illustrating this let's let's imagine a
person with a million dollars of savings
and they go to their local bank
and invest it in a CD getting five
percent all right something very simple
so they're making fifty thousand dollars
a year of income and let's suppose the
interest in dividends tax which is now
four percent
right so they're going to pay from that
fifty thousand dollars of income two
thousand dollars of tax
all right this bill in January of 2025
the house bill 2 in January 2025 would
eliminate that two thousand dollars of
tax
okay
but what is the bank going to do with
that million dollars of capital that
they were just given
the bank is going to loan that to
somebody who's going to build with it
right they're going to create housing
they're going to create commercial
property something like that they're
going to create a million dollars worth
of property
now our property taxes are roughly two
percent
so we are going to collect on that
million dollars of property twenty
thousand dollars a year in property
taxes
so
um we're comparing here two thousand
dollars of interest and dividends tax
for you know forgiven or gotten rid of
to twenty thousand dollars gain in in
property tax
all right now that might seem like well
why can't we have both why can't we have
twenty two thousand dollars of tax
but the problem is people who invest and
have these kind of resources are mobile
I I certainly have friends who are no
longer Granite Staters because they've
moved to Florida specifically because of
the interest and dividends tax
okay
and this is particularly Timely
this is particularly timely because of
what's Happening Now in Massachusetts
Massachusetts
first of all just in general
Massachusetts is losing roughly a
billion dollars a year of income people
people with income of a billion dollars
a year are fleeing Massachusetts and
when they do 50 percent of them move to
Florida 25 percent of them move here and
the other 25 percent move somewhere else
all right so Florida is getting twice as
many of the people who leave
Massachusetts as we are why is that
it doesn't make any sense to me right
why would somebody go to the Heat
the swamps the alligators
Etc
when they could live in New Hampshire
without the traffic with the lakes with
the mountains all that nice stuff what's
the difference remember we'll spend the
house will be in order
member has a right to be heard it's
getting awful loud
what's the difference
right the difference is the interest in
dividends tax
right if you can go to Florida and not
have your income taxed
maybe you'll do that instead of moving
to New Hampshire
so we want those investments in New
Hampshire we want that capital in New
Hampshire
and so this is particularly timely
because Massachusetts has just
put an extra large tax which is going to
force way more people out
and once they make the decision of where
to live
that's going to be their decision for a
long period of time so we should do this
now
it is not a large amount of money but
it's the kind of money that is seed
Capital Seed corn if you will for the
economy
and when we have Seed corn we don't want
to consume it
we want to plant it we want to let it
grow
and so then we can consume the results
thank you Mr Speaker
Janet Sweeney has requested a roll call
is that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote
foreign
the motion before us members will be in
their seats
the motion before us is floor Amendment
1290 it's a roll call vote share
recognizes representative Olney for a
parliamentary inquiry
if I know that a lot of our citizens
property taxes are much higher than two
percent of their income
and they would be surprised to know that
other people don't have that problem if
I know that the state of our economy and
of our state's revenues over the next
two biennia is very fragile
with continuing inflation and the odds
of recession rising and falling by the
week
and if I know that the IND tax is our
fifth largest revenue source and that
its disappearance is likely to threaten
our state county and Municipal Bond
ratings as well as to prevent valuable
investments in our future
and finally if I want to see our state's
economy and communities continue to grow
despite the economic clouds will I then
press the green button to remove this
dangerous threat from our budget
do you recognize ribs in a Sweeney for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that our state's interests in
dividends tax is an income tax and Mr
Speaker if I know that by accelerating
the phase out of the interest in
dividends tax we will be making New
Hampshire income tax free in this
biennium in this budget and further Mr
Speaker if I know that this
phase out acceleration of the interest
in dividends tax was part of a
bipartisan compromise within division
one of the finance committee to make it
so that we can pass a budget that all
can live with and Mr Speaker if I know
that we should pass relief for our
senior citizens and granted traders of
all stripes and backgrounds and make our
state more appreciated and more uh
welcoming to out-of-staters would I now
press the red button to preserve the
bipartisan compromise that division one
worked out thank you
the motion before us is the floor
Amendment stringum floor Amendment 1290
cyrol call vote if you're in favor we'll
press the green button to be oppose
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
foreign
[Music]
thank you
Ross and Mr Speaker
well Memphis president had an
opportunity to vote also attend state of
the vote
190 voting yay 199 voting a
motion fails
those on Second Amendment open till
further Amendment uh second reading open
to further Amendment
floor meant representative Heath offers
floor Amendment 1335
chair recognizes representative Heath
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker New Hampshire towns of
municipalities have endured a 10-year
moratorium on building Aid I ask you Mr
Speaker to join with me in bringing much
needed building Aid identified in
Amendment 1335
and the ability to cover the costs of
more than just three building projects
building Aid currently calls for 22.6
million in 2024
26.1 million in 25 this amendment would
add 10 million to each year the biennium
building brain building Aid in 24 to
32.6 million and in 20 in 2024 and 36.1
million in 2025
payments to the tail
will include 20.5 million and
17.2 million
um that is found in another budget line
so Mr Speaker I ask you to join with me
in helping our towns and municipalities
by voting yes on this amendment thank
you Mr Speaker
okay the motion before us is the floor
Amendment 1335.
are you ready for the question
a division has been requested members
take your seats
motion before us
is the heath floor Amendment 1335 this
is a division vote
chair recognizes representative Kate
Murray for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Mr Speaker if I
know that the motorium on school
building has created a backlog of badly
needing building projects and if I know
that many schools are in dire need of
building Aid and we have an opportunity
in front of us today to address this
batlog which in the long run will
benefit the entire State easing this
burden across the state across all
school districts
when I now press the green button and
support this amendment addressing a
critical need of our schools and school
building projects thank you Mr Speaker
and I represent a while of her
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that
building Aid was created
when the school enrollment was
increasing and all the schools needed
help in adding classrooms adding schools
and subsequently
the enrollment is shrinking
so we stopped giving building a we went
on a moratorium
now we see some of those
schools are wasting
the assets that they have they have
empty schools that's an asset that
should be maximized this is
parliamentary inquiry and if I know that
should be maximized
by selling that empty building so that
they could do other repairs and if I
know that the reasons for the moratorium
still exist
and we're already I know that we're
already paying off earlier mistakes from
2010 and how the education building Aid
was funded would I now press the red
button for this unnecessary Amendment
the motion before is the heat four
Amendment 1335 this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button of your opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
all members president an opportunity to
vote also attend the state of the vote
189 148 194 vote in May
Amendment fails
bills on second reading open to further
Amendment
representative Heath office floor
Amendment 1292
chair recognizes representative peace
thank you Mr Speaker
HB
I'm sorry Amendment 1292 is simple
it deletes sections six and seven from
hb2 and would therefore continue to
provide a retirement option for New
Hampshire employees of the community
college system of New Hampshire
currently
ccsnh provides the opportunity for new
employees the choice of either State
retirement or a 403 b plan
sections 6 and 7 of hb2 allows only the
402b option
73 percent of new community college
employees select the New Hampshire State
Retirement System choice
without passing this amendment they
would only have the 403 b plan Mr
Speaker please join me in supporting our
future
ccsnh employees by voting yes on
Amendment 1292h providing the option for
the State Retirement System of and a 402
B plan thank you Mr Speaker
chair recognize representative Dan
Maguire
thank you very much Mr Speaker
the provision that's being removed by
this amendment was a request by the
community college system and exceeded to
by the governor I was actually quite
surprised to see it in the budget but
what it what it does
is it gives the community college system
the same retirement plan that the
university system has had for I think
about 15 years
so it's a 403 b plan which is you know
similar to an IRA or 401k or something
like that
and it and the main feature of it is
that it's portable
so the the plan allows uh people to work
for I think it's vesting in three years
but if they only work for the system for
three years or four years or five years
and so on they can take their savings
with them the current retirement system
requires require requires you to work
for 10 years and according to the
community college system that they're
finding that that is unattractive to the
Gen Z's and gen x's and gen y's that
they're they are in the process of
hiring
so this this plan again it's the same
thing that the university system has had
that the community college system would
like to join them
thank you Mr Speaker
the motion before us is the heat floor
Amendment one two nine two
are you ready for the question
the vision has been requested
who requested a roll call
is that sufficiently it is sufficiently
seconded this will be a roll call vote
officer
clear
the motion before us
is the E4 Amendment one two nine two
this is a role call vote
Carrick and I
yeah
nothing
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button
every opposal press the red button
before the installations are open
okay
I made another mistake I'm sorry
uh chair recognizes uh representative
Kate Murray for a parliamentary injury
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that currently the
community college system employees are
very happy and they value that they have
a choice between joining the New
Hampshire retirement system or the
college system of the New Hampshire's
plan and if I know this bill removes
their choice
and if I know that we did not have a
full understanding of the change this
impact would have on the already
strained New Hampshire retirement system
or the impact on the individual who
moves from one system to another or the
recruitment of future faculty when I
press the green button to support the
amendment and continue to give the
community college employees a choice in
their retirement plans thank you Mr
Speaker
gear recognize representative Wilder for
a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that canceling this amendment gives us
the opportunity to view within the state
system the Define contribution
retirement plan and if I further know
from personal experience that I had both
Retirement Systems Define contribution
and Define benefit and if I further know
that even though the defined benefit was
funded at almost twice what the defined
contribution was
when I took them both in lump sums at
retirement
the retired the
the contribution
was greater than the benefit I think we
should all be able to see
the results of doing this on an
experimental basis and I ask you to push
the red button
the motion before us is the heat for
Amendment one two nine two this is a
roll call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if your opposed
or press the red button voting stations
are open for 30 seconds
okay
while members president had an
opportunity to vote household 10 state
of the vote
199 voting a 187 voting a the amendment
is adopted
bills on second reading open to further
Amendment
the
representative Heath office floor
Amendment 1313
and the chair recognized representative
Heath
thank you Mr Speaker
Amendment 1313 restores from the general
fund to the education Trust
School building Aid tuition and
transportation special education Aid
building a lease episode treatment court
ordered placements Mr Speaker this
amendment protects these critical
education programs within the safety of
the education trust and therefore does
not force these important areas to
compete with other important general
fund areas Mr Speaker I ask for your
support for Amendment 1313 thank you Mr
Speaker
thank you
chair recognizes representative Hall
thank you Mr Speaker trying to
in the pile of amendments trying to get
to this last one so I can talk to 1313h
at the end of the day
um
this modifies the education trust fund
at some level and
when the governor sent the budget over
to us he changed the proportioning in
the system
from the old take a certain percentage
of the money that was taken to a
percentage of the total funds
furthermore
the finance committee further amended
that
when the finance committee excuse me
when the finance committee amended that
we did so with the intent
to make sure that education excuse me
education related items were funded out
of the education trust fund
and that balanced and it would be
important to support that effort
and oppose this committee and thank you
who requested the Roll Call
representative barrier requests and roll
calls that's efficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote
okay
today
the motion before us is the heat four
Amendment 1313 chair recognizes
representative luno for a parliamentary
inquiry
Mr Speaker if I know this amendment
I'm sorry Mr Speaker if I know this
amendment restores the integrity and
purpose
purposes of the education trust fund
and if I know this amendment includes
education Freedom accounts as one of the
purposes of the education trust fund
then would I press the green button to
vote Yes on this amendment thank you Mr
Speaker
do you recognize representative Wilder
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Mr Seeker if I know
that when I helped create
the education trust fund it was there
specifically to pay for adequacy and
used a portion of the general fund
to assign to that and if I further know
that as
subsequently the enrollment has shrunk
by about a third meaning that the amount
of money that went into that fund
was more than it needed to have and it
froze those funds so they couldn't be
used elsewhere
and if I further know that my amendment
was what restored it to its historical
use for only adequacy and not to create
an education slush fund that people
would be seeking places to use elsewhere
would I now press the red button
to restore it where it should be thank
you
motion before us the heat floor
Amendment 1313 this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button of your opposed or press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
oh my God
[Music]
members president an opportunity to vote
house will attend the state of the vote
191 voting yay 197 voting a the
amendment fails
bills on second reading open to further
Amendment
representative munz office floor
Amendment 1339
chair recognizer representative muns
thank you Mr Speaker and good morning
colleagues
I Rise to offer floor Amendment 2023
1339 which will redirect 6 million
dollars currently allocated to the
University of system of New Hampshire
for the purposes of renovating
Whittemore Arena to the system's block
allocation from the general fund the
member will suspend for a minute
if you need to have a conversation take
it out into the ante room and please do
it quietly the member has a right to
speak
thank you Mr chair Mr Speaker it will
take the money and put it in the block
allocation from the general fund that is
used and will be used to reduce tuition
for in-state students
three million dollars will be allocated
in each fiscal year and the net effect
will be to reduce in-state tuition by
between 230 and 310 dollars per year
depending on which campus the student
resides on
that is the equivalent of it to a
savings of two percent in tuition costs
for all in-state students enrolled at
UNH Keene State or Plymouth state
I'm not anti-college Sports and I'm not
anti-unh
I played Sports in in college and as my
friend the State Rep from Barrington can
attest I continue to play soccer into my
60s
my wife is a graduate of unh and we held
season tickets for hockey at the wit for
many years
there's nothing I would like to see more
than UNH return to the Frozen four and
bring home a national championship to
New Hampshire
but several weeks ago my niece's
daughter who has his clothes who is as
close to a granddaughter as I currently
have and who is an honors student at
Cole Brown Academy in Northwood
announced that she will be attending the
University of South Carolina this fall
she is going there in in part at least
because it will cost her less to do so
as an out-of-state student in South
Carolina than it would to go to UNH as
an in-state student
as we all know too well New Hampshire
has the second highest average cost of
in-state tuition and fees in the country
only Vermont is higher
that is because previous legislatures
have consistently underfunded our
state's University system
that is also one of the reasons why New
Hampshire has one of the highest levels
of student debt in the country
and it's telling that only
48.7 percent of the full-time students
attending the university system are in
fact New Hampshire residents
in addition to imposing a real financial
burden on students and families across
our state
we are also hurting ourselves
when my niece graduates from the
University of South Carolina the chances
of her returning to New Hampshire and
contributing to the fabric of our
community here will be much less than if
she had gone to college here
my own daughter went to school in
Washington DC
and guess what that's where she lives
today
there is only one state in the country
Maine whose population is on average
older than ours
if we continue to make it more expensive
for students who want to go to college
in New Hampshire
we will just continue to get older and
older as a population which will create
additional serious economic and
budgetary challenges for the
legislatures who will be sitting here 5
10 and 20 years from now
I have no doubt that renovating the
Whittemore Center will make it a much
more appealing venue for alumni and
local businesses leaders who live in the
Durham area
to attend and and take their games to a
hockey game or a concert
and I'm sure that it will generate some
additional revenue for unh
UNH already has commitments of of over
34 million dollars in private donors
towards the cost of those Renovations
and I'm sure that they could raise the
remainder of the amount themselves
I'm also very aware that six million
dollars will not fix the imbalance in
tuition costs that now exists we should
do more much more
given the other budget challenges we are
trying to address today that is a
discussion for another day
but until we have that discussion I
believe we need to do whatever we can to
make our University system more
affordable for more of our own students
and be willing to defer other nice to
have projects
this amendment will not increase the
budget
nor does it take away any money
allocated to the university system
what this amendment will do is move six
million dollars which is currently
allocated allocated specifically for
renovating expanding the Whittemore
Center during fy24 and move three
million dollars into the state's general
allocation of funds for fy24 and fy25
those funds will be utilized to reduce
ins in States in-state tuition and their
specific language in the amendment that
that says that which currently ranges
from between eleven thousand five
hundred and fifteen thousand five
hundred
they're approx approximately 10 700
full-time in-state students enrolled at
UNH Keene State and Plymouth State and
the additional three million dollars
this amendment will make will allocate
to the system will result in annual
Savings of between 230 and 310 dollars
or 920 or 1240 over four years to
students and families across New
Hampshire
it's not enough but it's a start and it
represents real tangible savings for New
Hampshire families that we can deliver
today without increasing the budget
I hope you will join me in supporting
these families by voting in favor of
this amendment and Mr Speaker I request
a division vote please press the green
button
to support this amendment thank you
thank you Mr Speaker and honorable
Representatives
I want to Echo uh the thoughts from my
friend from Hampton
that we need to lower the cost of
in-state tuition for the University
system of New Hampshire
students are struggling and are paying
more to go to schools that are tax
dollars fund than they are to go to
out-of-state universities
this is an opera you give students a
small break because UNH has already
received funding from private donors to
upgrade the Whittemore Center
while these improvements are nice and
would include upgraded HVAC systems
audio improvements and modifications for
rink seating
these upgrades are not necessarily being
benefited by the students the students
are still paying more and are struggling
and the state has a pattern of using
student tuition to offset the costs
that the university usually takes on
I'm asking all of you to support this
amendment as a way to lower the cost of
tuition for students in something that
is already allocated in our budget
thank you
cure recognize representative Emrick
thank you Mr Speaker
my colleague from Rock Rockingham
has kind of missed the point
the point of this six million dollars
which came to us and financed and the
governor's not a budget is
recommendation input okay on the
governor's input
the the chancellor of the University sat
before us and explained the winamore
center
rebuild is a 30 million dollar project
what they're looking for is for the
state to kick in something to show that
we support the University
that's the point it's not about tuition
it's about do we support UNH are we
proud of what we've done and if you've
gone to the Whittemore Center and
watched athletes warm up in the Halls
you know we haven't provided the best
environment for our athletes
this upgrade will also allow the center
to be used for other Gatherings
entertainment venue and I I think that's
the point of this six million dollars
originally it came in at eight million
dollars but the chancellor agreed six
million dollars they can get the
matching funds
if they don't get the six million
dollars the project dies
the the contributors
alumni that are pledging to this project
it depends on us kicking in six million
dollars so if you want to kill the
project vote for this amendment
but if you know it the project should go
forward hit the red button thank you Mr
Speaker
representative munz has requested a
division members
representative turkot is requested are
all calls that's officially seconded it
is sufficiently seconded
members take your seats this will be a
roll call vote
foreign
[Music]
the motion before us
is the muns floor Amendment 1339
care recognize is going to be a roll
call vote share recognized
representative muns for a parliamentary
inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know that New Hampshire has the
second highest cost of in-state tuition
and fees in the country
and that New Hampshire has one of the
highest levels of student debt in the
country
and that as a result only 48 percent of
the students attending UNH Keene State
and Plymouth state are actually from New
Hampshire
and if I know that the legislature is
proud of and has consistently
demonstrated its support of unh over the
years and that now is the time to show
our support for these in-state students
attending the university system of New
Hampshire
and if I know that by voting in favor of
this amendment I will reduce the cost of
tuition for New Hampshire students
residents who wish to attend New
Hampshire by between 920 and 1240 over
the course of four years and finally if
I know that I can provide these students
and their families these savings without
increasing the budget we are discussing
here today would I now press the green
button to vote in favor of this
amendment thank you
chair recognize representative Emrick
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know this funding is not about
tuition
and if I know if we don't provide this
funding this project will not go forward
would I now press the red button
the motion before us is the mum's four
Amendment 1339 it's a roll call vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button of your post or press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
thank you
all members president opportunity vote
household 10 State the vote
128 voting a 100 259 40 Navy Amendment
fails
all right
the bill is still on second reading and
open a further Amendment representative
Alessandra Murray moves floor Amendment
1299 and is recognized to speak to her
Amendment
thank you Mr Speaker
Amendment 1299 age is a very simple
amendment that removes the authorization
of an appropriation for the northern
border Alliance program
we've made it clear in this body that we
do not support using State funds to
enforce Federal Regulations but this
section of hb2 would not only use
taxpayer money to do exactly that but
would also increase the authority of
state and local police far beyond what
our communities are comfortable with
we've made it clear in New Hampshire
that we are Harbor of safety for those
seeking freedom and liberty whether they
come from out of state or out of the
country in fact my own immigrant family
came here when I was five years old to
raise their family and we've been here
ever since
a program
that allows our taxpayer money to pay
police to roam unchecked on Northern
properties stopping and racial profiling
whomever they want is enough to keep
families like mine from feeling welcome
in this state
this program is built on the wild
assumption that Northern New Hampshire
has an extreme problem with illegal
border crossings yet despite informal
and formal requests neither the governor
nor any state agency including the
department of safety has provided any
data on authorized on unauthorized
border entries into New Hampshire or of
apprehensions of Border crosses crossers
within New Hampshire to support these
supposed concerns I'm not sure why we
would Institute such an unregulated
program without any data or studies to
indicate it's needed
with an implementation date of June 30th
2023 this program is simply too
undefined and too rushed to pass through
this budget taxpayer money for police
should directly assist in meeting
Community needs and priorities not take
away from those commitments to instead
focus on enforcing Federal Regulations
this program is a massive intrusion on
local control and contravenes New
Hampshire's Live Free or Die values in
history
our local officials do not do the
bidding of the federal government and if
you agree with me I ask you to please
vote green on the ought to pass motion
thank you Mr Speaker
representative hole is recognizing
it would be disingenuous if I got up
this morning and talked about spending
when there was an opportunity to cut
spending that is a task of the federal
government
while it's not much it's 1.4 million
it does in fact reduce the spending this
year
for a program that really should be run
by the federal government our borders
are are designated to the federal
government via the U.S Constitution that
is not a New Hampshire state
constitution item
furthermore it does allow for the first
25 miles police officers to have
warrantless arrest capabilities
I've spoken before on that I can't think
of a more
unconstitutional power that we could
give to state government than allowing
them to arrest people without a warrant
I would support the the adoption of 1299
each thank you
the question is whether to adopt four
Amendment 1299 H are you ready for the
question
somebody called division yeah okay
this will be a division vote members
take receipts
the questions whether to adopt Amendment
1299 H this is a division vote
representative South kedis is recognized
for parliamentary inquiry
[Music]
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know that our border with Canada is
the largest peacetime Border in the
world at 500 I mean 5
535 miles
and if I know that the only part of it
that concerns New Hampshire is 59 miles
and if I know that equals 250
a mile for increasing the federal
intrusion into our
um Live Free or Die lives what I then
press the green button thank you
representative Weiler is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that our country is being flooded with
illegal immigrants not only on the
southern border but also on the northern
border
and if I expect to have cooperation
between the border patrol and once these
immigrants enter our state they're going
to be a problem for our state and local
police so I would be happy to see
cooperation between those forces to
protect our state and our people I would
now press the red button
the questions whether to adopt Amendment
1299h this is a division vote if you're
in favor press the green button if
you're opposed press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
thank you
spirits of evil devotes
[Music]
representative Richards
of all members presence had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attended the state of the
vote
241 in the affirmative 143 and the
negative the Amendments adopted
representative Edwards offers floor
amendments one two seven two and is
recognized to speak to his motion
uh thank you so much
this this is this is probably the
simplest thing you're going to see all
day inside of uh hb2 there was a uh an
item that uh identified a Civics
commission that would help facilitate
and support the development of civics
curriculum for the our school system and
in the process of putting that together
one of the things one of the vital
groups that got left out was the New
Hampshire Historical Society
so uh so I was contacted representative
moffatt has been in deep liaison with
that organization we were contacted and
asked if we could add the New Hampshire
Historical Society back I don't I don't
think this is controversial if if no one
from the other side is going to speak
against us this could be my pi as well
and I would ask you to vote green
questions whether to adopt floor
amendments 1272 H you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
all those opposing a
H swinging a mess
the Amendments adopted
the bill remains on second reading and
open a further Amendment
representative contrast moves Amendment
one two eight three
and as recognized to speak to your
Amendment
I'm Gonna Leave It Off
thank you Mr speaker thank you members
this is a very simple Bill all it does
is say there are currently six vacant
positions
in the department and we're currently
funding 32 positions and it reduces it
to 29. and I would just ask that you
support this thank you
okay
the questions whether to adopt Amendment
one two eight three h are you ready for
the question oh division has been
requested this will be a division vote
members take receipts
clear
oh I didn't know
okay
the question is whether adopt Amendment
1283h representative Edwards is
recognized for parliamentary inquiry
uh thank you Mr Speaker
um uh if if if I believe that the
Department's request to have uh 32
attorneys available to them to do their
caseload and if I believed that a
reduction of 3 to 29 might harm their
ability to provide the services to the
public would I then vote red
the questions rather adopt an amendment
1283h this is a division vote if you're
in favor press the green button if
you're opposed press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
[Music]
thank you
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attended the state of the vote
158 in the affirmative 226 and negative
the amendment fails
I would like to take this opportunity to
share something with you from Masons
from section 122 breaches of the order
of the house
during debate while the presiding
officer is speaking or the house is
engaged in voting no one is to disturb
another in a speech by hissing coughing
spitting speaking or whispering to
another and we're passing between the
presiding officer and the member
speaking nor crossing the floor of the
house nor walking up and down nor taking
books or papers from the desk
not writing there nor writing there
so
while people are speaking
some of you have gotten a little
enthusiastic about making noise to
express your approval or disapproval
don't do that
and also when someone is speaking at one
of the wells these two aisles don't use
them it's
if it's happened to you you get it it's
really disconcerting to be speaking at
the well and somebody just comes walking
down right at your face
there's an aisle on the side that you
can use so let's try to get this back
together where it belongs
12.95
the bill remains on second reading and
further open a further Amendment
representative Prout office floor
Amendment 1295 and is recognized to
speak to his motion
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker this amendment would delete
section 135 of house bill 2.
current law limits the auxiliary State
Police to no more than 16 members
this limit was added back in 2013 in
Senate Bill 165 as a trade-off when the
number of days per year they could serve
on active duty was removed
section 135 removes the 16-member limit
with no trade-off
membership of the auxiliary State Police
has few limitations the person must be a
New Hampshire citizen 20 year 21 years
old and have no felony convictions there
are uniforms and equipment are paid for
by the state
they're compensated at rates set by the
director when on duty
the removal of this limitation would
allow the state police to grow to
essentially any size
the only real limitation would be funds
to pay for them
with opportunities to use federal funds
such as to continue the failed drug war
augment border patrol or any other task
force funded by whatever Administration
happens to be in power at the time
if you do not want to see the New
Hampshire police state growing excuse me
I mean the New Hampshire State Police
grow unchecked
by any controls of this legislature then
please press the green button to pass
this amendment delete this section and
leave the 16-member limitation in place
thank you Mr Speaker
the question is whether to adopt
Amendment one two nine five-h
representative prep requested division
vote this will be a division vote
members please take the seats
foreign
representative Rosner is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you if I know that Amendment 1295
presents a simple common sense and
bipartisan counter to a concerning
Loosely defined and unnecessary
expansion of police power
and if I know that the people of New
Hampshire deserve an appropriately
structured and responsive use of state
power including in the organization of
our police to address emergency
situations would I now encourage us to
vote to adopt Amendment 1295 thank you
representative Wilder is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
if I know that the auxiliary State
Police are seldom used and then most of
them if I further know that most of them
are retired police and have experience
in what they're doing and if I further
know that if it occasion arises that the
state police need more people where else
can they get them from I would vote red
to allow them this slight emergency use
thank you
the questions whether to adopt Amendment
1295 H this is a division vote if you're
in favor press the green button if
you're opposed press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
okay
representative Egan
of all members present and an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
2 49 in the affirmative 136 and the
negative the Amendments adopted
representative duchette moves floor
Amendment
1328 and is recognized to speak to his
motion
thank you Mr Speaker and thank you
colleagues and I rival the assertion by
my colleague from Auburn this is going
to be relatively fast fast and simple
what my Amendment does is uh has us
codify a vote we took less
session that we met in relation to
charitable gaming simply the expansion
of the one game that the legislature
passed into law last biennium the
historic horse racing allowing for ample
time to review revenue for both the
state and the Charities I won't get into
the long discussion about the five years
being ample time it may take longer but
at least it gives them the five years
and I look forward to your support on
this amendment thank you Mr Speaker
questions whether to adopt Amendment
1328-h are you ready for the question
all in favor say aye
all those opposed nay
the eyes have it the amendment's adopted
representative Prout moves Amendment
1288 and is recognized to speak to his
motion
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker this amendment would add what
was House Bill 624 to the end of the
budget
this Bill had made it so that local
police when they learn of a border
patrol checkpoint like the ones that
have been happening at I-93
to require them to announce it to the
public
similar to how we require DUI
checkpoints run by local police to be
announced to the public
this is because of all the terrible
traffic scenarios when they do this in
I-93 just south of the notch keeping
people stuck on the highway for hours
hurting tourism the area
and also acting as a detainment on
everyone delayed
if you voted for House Bill 624 several
weeks ago when we passed it I hope you
will also press the green button and
vote for this as well
thank you
the question is whether to adopt
Amendment one two eight h
representative Pratt requested division
vote this will be a division vote
members please take your seats
things
questions whether to adopt Amendment one
two eight eight H and this is a division
vote
representative Newell's recognized for
parliamentary incorrect
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know that New Hampshire residents
and visitors value their right to move
freely without arbitrary search and
seizure
and if I know that the established
protocol a public notification when
sobriety checkpoints are planned are
working just fine
would I now push the
green button to adopt this amendment
representative Wireless recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
if we want to catch people if I know we
want to catch people bringing illegal
immigrants why would we let the coyotes
know where the checkpoint is
press the red button
the questions whether to adopt Amendment
1288h this is a division vote if you're
in favor press the green button opposed
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
thank you
representative peloso
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attended the state of the
vote
2 47 in the affirmative 139 and the
negative the Amendments adopted
representative Hull moves Amendment one
two seven six and is recognized to speak
to his motion
thank you Mr Speaker
this is a short Amendment does two
things the first is it corrects a small
clerical issue on regarding eligibility
the program has had a very consistent
eligibility requirement in drafting
the finance Amendment there was a small
change it made it through the system
this corrects the eligibility standard
secondly it moves the eligibility
regarding finances from the current 350
percent that the house has adopted to
just to put some numbers so that we all
understand in household dollars
a family of four the federal poverty
level is approximately thirty thousand
dollars
three hundred percent of that which is
the current law is ninety thousand
dollars for a family of four it's hard
to imagine with a family of four how to
pay bills pay a mortgage
and send children to a private school
with tuition somewhere between four and
twelve thousand dollars
this amendment will allow that to go up
to something that would be more
reasonable and allow additional people
to participate in the program
personally in the last 10 years I've
lived at the federal poverty level my
household income dropped significantly
and while I've never taken money from
the state to fund our children's
education
I can understand why there are families
who believe that this is necessary who
for the reasons of anything from
bullying to not getting the education
they need to feeling like they want to
they want something different whether
it's the teaching style the curriculum
they just want something different than
the than the solution proposed by the
state
I would ask that you would support this
floor Amendment and press green I'll ask
for a division vote
representative Guthrie is recognized
speak against the amendment
thank you Mr chairman
and a A late good morning to everybody
I raised to oppose this amendment uh
originally because of the concern about
the increase
uh in in a budget but really you have to
go looking more at the amendment I was
concerned that the 500 percent
uh going from 350 from to 500 percent of
Eligibility ability and this issue the
education Freedom account has been
discussed over and over uh if my memory
is right and at my age it might I might
have some concern about that but I think
that the issue of going from 300 to 350
uh out to 500 was better very recently
so I was I'm concerned that the 500
percent would come up again to make more
people eligible for the freedom
account so I'm more concerned ask you to
vote against and vote red
mainly because this is an issue that has
embedded over and over again it has been
looked at by the uh the finance
committee finance committee has
put information
and talked about that account in the
budget in the original budget and I
think it's prudent for us to put this in
the back burner and if we want to talk
about increasing those items we should
do it through the regular process going
letting it get vetted against if
necessary at the community level and
come back to the house if in fact it is
something that we need
so vote red please
ah it's just slow representative we're
proud has requested a roll call vote is
that sufficiently seconds it and it is
this will be a roll call vote members
please take your seats
here
all right the question is whether to
adopt Amendment one two seven six H this
is a roll call vote if you are in favor
press the green button if you're opposed
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
[Music]
of all members presence had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attended the state of the
vote
167 in the affirmative 222 and the
negative the amendment fails
the Bill's on second reading and opens
you get further Amendment
representative Prout moves Amendment
1332 and is recognized to speak to his
motion
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker we already heard earlier an
amendment about the Whitmore Center
why spending State funds to help upgrade
it
was unnecessary and not a wise use of
our tax dollars
how this amendment differs from the
earlier one is what to do with those
funds once that section is deleted
this amendment will just reduce State
spending and send that money back to the
rainy day fund and eventually the
taxpayers
please press the green button
to reduce the size of this budget thank
you
the question is whether adopt Amendment
1332h and representative proutner has
requested a division vote this will be a
division vote members take your seats
the questions whether to adopt Amendment
1332h
representative Prout was recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
if I know
at the Whitmore Center will likely
receive its 30 million dollar renovation
through other sources of funds whether
or not we include this six million
dollars of State funding forward
and I know that passing this amendment
would reduce the budget by six million
dollars would I press the green button
thank you
representative Kate Murray is recognized
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know at present the Whittemore
Center is the only facility of all local
universities in the Northeast not yet
renovated which has been a problem for
its with regarding to attracting
students and not just the athletes
if I know this is a public private and
state-funded project
which is new where they want to show
that we have some skin in the game to
support this program
if I know that this enhances a revenue
stream for the University not just for
sports but for events and for New
Concepts in fact new to meet Concepts in
terms of e-gaming
and if I know that students who attend
the University of New Hampshire stay in
New Hampshire they live here they work
here they raise their families here
and in this way the new University of
New Hampshire is a partner with us and
finally if I know that
the general the university has agreed
that if the general court ever needs to
use their facility again for a house
session they won't charge us
would I please press the red button
to defeat this amendment thank you Mr
Speaker
the question is whether to adopt
Amendment 1332h this is a division vote
if you're in favor press the red the
press the green button and if you're
opposed press the red button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
thank you
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attended the state of the
vote
158 in the affirmative 231 in the
negative the amendment fails
representative Harrington moves four
amendments one two eight four and is
recognized
okie dokie
this will be Pi's only a division vote
members please take your seats
ladies and gentlemen we'll next after
this amendment be voting on Amendment
1333 from representative hole it is a
very large document if you have not yet
received that it it was sent for print
yesterday afternoon and they have not we
finally just got the last shipment of
them if you do not have them please
raise your hands so I can keep track of
where they need to go
all right
the questions whether to adopt Amendment
one two eight four h
this is a division vote
if you're oh okay
representative Harrington's recognized
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that the this amendment would
simply not add another staff member to
the office of the consumer Advocate who
already has open positions if I know
that the budget that we were proposing
has 75 thousand dollars from those open
positions that could be used to hire
contractors that could fulfill this
representation of the of the Office of
Consumer Advocate at Regional meetings
if I know that we already have
representation through Nesco neck Puck
and we have a full-time employee of
Department of energy who does that and I
know that the Office of Consumer
Advocate is already doing a good job at
that and I know authorizing another
position that they can't fill will
accomplish nothing and I know this
amendment would save over a hundred
thousand dollars a year would I please
press the green button
representative McGee's recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know that the consumer Advocates
office is trying to
accommodate a change to the law in 2021
by my colleague who's bringing this
amendment that states that the consumer
Advocate shall Advocate against
provisional activities and that this
position is designed to meet that goal
which is a requirement now in the rsas
and that there currently are no staff
people available to monitor those
Regional activities so that they can
actually do this kind of enforcement
than what I now press the red button
thank you
we're in the voting mode
the questions whether adopt Amendment
one two eight four h this is a division
vote if you're in favor press the green
button opposed press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
my sister
have all members presence had an
opportunity to vote
the house will intent of the state of
the vote
182 in the affirmative 205 and the
negative the amendment fails
representative hole moves floor
Amendment
1333 and is recognized to speak to his
motion
I'm not going to read it
don't rest assured
so what is amendment 1333h
in summary
it's the committee Finance or the
finance committee Amendment
with a few small changes
well no I I do mean that in small
changes
but structurally for for a tactical
reason I changed section one which
forced the renumbering of the finance
committee Amendment all the way through
which changed
and if you do that that would have
nullified and someone else pointed it
out this morning would have nullified
all the other amendments on the floor
today that we could have even talked
about
so it would have given us a simple
solution to a one vote
on the budget
you may or may not agree with that
choice but at least it would have
shortened our day
so it is the finance committee Amendment
as adopted by this house it does not
contain however
the amendment proposed by the members
from Manchester and Auburn
it does contain the change for the efes
that we just talked about
it also does something important which
is what I talked about this morning it
keeps our spending and our revenues on
parity
it makes cuts it level funds the UNH
system
it gets rid of the Whitmore rank
or whatever the funding for the the
Whitmore Renovations it level funds the
community college system
it provides 85 percent of the requested
employee raise for the state employees
so instead of 10 raise they get an eight
and a half percent raise
with these cuts to the budget
we are now equal to the to our Revenue
stream and for those that want to manage
Finance is you have to link the two you
can't just pretend that there's
additional revenues coming in or what
we've seen in the past which is we're
taking the excess revenues from last
year and spending them to prop up this
budget
I would ask that you would support it
I'll ask for a division vote thank you
the question is whether to adopt
Amendment
1333h representative Holz requested a
division vote this will be a division
vote members take their seats
foreign
the questions whether to adopt Amendment
1333h this is a division vote
representative
representative Weiler is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know that the prime sponsor of this
bill
was a member of the committee that
brought you the amendment that we voted
on first
and if I know he had opportunities in
both the division and the full committee
to bring amendments
and if I further know that this is just
too much
for us to try to digest and figure out
what the changes are
what I now press the red button rather
than destroy everything we've already
accepted thank you
questions whether to adopt Amendment
1333h if you're in favor press the green
button if you're opposed press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
foreign
members presence had an opportunity to
vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
72 in the affirmative 300 and the
negative the amendment fails
the bill remains on second reading and
opened a further Amendment
representative verval moves Amendment
one two seven three and is recognized to
speak to his motion
thank you Mr Speaker
thank you colleagues
good morning
it's been a long morning I won't bore
you too too much today
if we're going to spend all these green
backs today
shouldn't we send some green back to our
constituents
[Music]
some common sense cannabis reform laws
into place into this state
isn't it time that we do what the vast
majority of our constituents poll after
poll after poll year after year after
year are begging us to do
isn't it time
we've passed a lot of amendments we just
passed a big you know we're going to
pass a big hb2 and it's got a little
something for you and it's got a little
something for you it might even have a
little something for me but how about we
put something in here
with really bipartisan
widespread appeal to the vast majority
of our constituents
please
join me in sending some green back to
our constituents by pressing the green
button
and getting this common legislation
Common Sense legislation finally passed
in New Hampshire thank you Mr Speaker
the questions whether to adopt Amendment
1273 age are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
all those opposed nay
[Music]
that's all right I can't tell let's do a
clarification vote nobody and nobody out
no this is a clarification vote
okay
yeah someone clarification votes is just
to find out which way it went there's no
pis none of that just vote so if you're
in favor press the green button oppose
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
foreign
of all members presence had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attended the state of the
vote
160 very loud folks in the affirmative
214 and the negative the amendment fails
the motion before us now is on hb2 on a
pass as Amendment
chair recognizes representative hoole
I think this is my last time up here
today at least I hope
you've heard the arguments against the
budget multiple times you've heard that
this spends too much
spends more than we take in in Revenue
we just added between various amendments
something close to another 80 million
dollars in new spending
when you put together a plan
that doesn't take into account the
declining revenues we're seeing out of
the dra
and spends all that we take in plus
almost another 300 million dollars in
round numbers
approximately 18 percent
more than less budget
probably closer to 19 now I'd have to do
some more math
it's a hard thing to go back and defend
to your constituents
that that was a good policy
I would ask that you would post the auto
pass motion so that we can potentially
figure out another solution thank you
I recognize representative Weiler
thank you Mr Speaker
it's been a long morning
and
we've done a lot of rearranging of what
was passed but I think we can make it
work
it's been as I said a bipartisan budget
there's something in there for all of us
and if we're going to be able to defend
it when it goes to the Senate we have to
pass it otherwise we don't have anything
to argue with
so it's this is a very important vote
please reinforce what we've spent all
our time and our first very important
amendment that we did to this and the
second very important Amendment so
very important that we have something to
negotiate with the Senate I appreciate
all the inputs that I've had from you
and I hope you will press the green
green green green button please thank
you
the motion before us is the auto pass
has emitted motion on hb2
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
well supposedly
[Applause]
the eyes have it in hb2 is passed
without objection the clerk has
authorized to make Technical and
administrative Corrections which are
necessary to reflect the intent of the
house
um
majority of the committee on financed
which was referred House Bill 1A enact
making Appropriations for the expenses
of certain Departments of the state for
fiscal years ending June 30th 2024 and
June 30th 2025. consider the same report
the same with the following Amendment
recommendation to build a lot of
password Amendment Senator Ken Weiler
for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee
and considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
following resolution that is inexpeding
to legislate represent Mary Jane Wallner
for the minority of the committee
the amendment is one two four four-h
printed in house record 18a page one are
you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say aye
you guys haven't and the amendment is
adopted the bill before the motion
before us now is ought to pass with
Amendment are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
Mr opposed me the eyes have it and the
house bill one is adopted
I can have it back
just so everyone knows we're going to
take lunch around 12 30.
committee on finance the wassues
Deferred House Bill 46 FN enact
establishing a committee to study
replacement of Bill Commissioners with
court magistrates could citizen report
the same with the following Amendment
and the recommendation of the fill out a
password Amendment Senator Dan McGuire
for the committee the amendment is zero
nine one five H put it in house record
18 page 30. are you ready for the
question on the amendment all those in
favor say aye those opposed nay the eyes
have it amendment is adopted the motion
before us now is ought to pass with
Amendment are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye proposed a
the eyes have it and the committee
report is adopted
majority committee on finance to which
it was referred House Bill 74 FN
relative to employees unused earned time
having considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolve that is inexpedient to legislate
representative Jose Campbell is for the
majority of the committee minority of
the committee have been considered the
same being unable to agree with the
majority report the recommendations Bill
ought to pass Karen evil for the
minority of the committee
chair recognizes representative grassy
thank you Mr Speaker
Horizon opposition to the motion on the
floor before you today
House Bill 74 was a relatively simple
bill which passed this house previously
from the policy committee
and what it does is it only impacts
companies that have 15 or more employees
it requires that they have a policy
that they keep track of your earned time
for sick and vacation pay
and it doesn't really cost the state
anything at all so you know wondering
what was the fiscal impact of this well
they said it was 2.4 million dollars so
that's if we laid off all of the state
employees tomorrow
it would affect us to that point
it really is an impact here as far as
the budget is concerned
let me just tell you a little story
because
you're going to hear that this doesn't
affect a lot of people
what it does do is that if someone is to
be laid off
let's just say that when covet hit
your company told you that well we're
going to have a layoff soon here we
don't know what's going on
and one day you get a call you got to
show up to work early
and the public Human Services human
the Personnel person is there to tell
you that
they're going to shut down the business
at midnight that night
and you say
well what about my health insurance do I
have that till the end of the month and
they say no you don't it ends at
midnight
your first thought
back it's
am I going to be get paid for my
benefits my unused vacation time and
besides the employee that's sitting
right next to me use their two weeks of
vacation last month
and I've got four weeks of vacation
coming up because I was there for 10
years
and but am I going to get my vacation
time you're not thinking about that
you're thinking about am I going to be
able to pay the rent tomorrow
how am I going to meet my electric bill
am I going to be able to feed my kids
so when it comes in you get your
paycheck
and there's no vacation time there
that's not what you're paying attention
to
you're worried about am I going to get
my unemployment
what am I going to do about my health
insurance
they'll tell you that this doesn't
affect a lot of people
but when a company has a policy
and anybody over 15 hour 15 people
employed were required you know if they
have a policy they'll be required to
tell you about it they'll be required to
keep track of those hours you'll know
how many hours you were when they give
you that Paula in that policy they give
you earns time sit time and vacation
time that's earned time
you worked for that time
and if it only affects one employee
it's a traumatic experience for that one
employee when they're told there's no
work tomorrow pick up your check on
Friday
you're more concerned about your family
your home your life
than you are on whether you got paid
your vacation time or not
if it affects one employee
we should pass this bill
because if we don't pass this bill
we are letting down
the person who works hard every day
gets earned vacation time
and basically is cheated out of that
vacation time
that story was a true story it was my
story
I'm asking you that you vote no on this
motion so another motion may be made
thank you
do you recognized representative
Campbell is
thank you Mr Speaker
this bill is a classic example of a
solution looking for a problem
the majority of the finance committee in
a bipartisan vote
deemed this bill to be inexperienced
legislate during the testimony for this
bill it became clear that this issue
affects only a tiny tiny fraction of the
New Hampshire Workforce
the data presenters show at a very low
number of complaints on this issue
that implies that the vast majority of
employers in the state already comply
with the Bill's objective as a matter of
good business policy
please join me in pressing the green
button to I tell the itl this Bill thank
you Mr Speaker
a division has been requested members
will take their seats
[Music]
the motion before us is the majority
committee report of inexpensed
legislature in house bill 74. this is a
division vote chair recognized
representative Michael Cahill for a
parliamentary inquiry
[Music]
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know you've just heard
the story from a one of our own a member
of this house
and if I also know that in just the past
eight months
the department of New Hampshire
Department of Labor has
500 wage claims and at 100 of those
involved earned a vacation time then I
would then was this week or would I not
say that this is only a small number of
people that it's a pretty significant
number of people
and Mr Speaker if I know this is not a
Democratic or republican issue that's an
issue of fairness this is evidenced by
the four Republican members who
co-sponsor this board with me but I now
press the red button so that another
motion may be made thank you Mr Speaker
chair recognized representative
infantine for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that this very well
intended bill
takes away the ability for employers to
decide how to compensate and reward
their employees
and if I know that additional small
minor changes to this language may be
able to result in a bill that we could
support or and I could I could support
but this isn't quite it
if I believe business owners
will make the right decisions on their
policies to support their workers and
finally Mr Speaker if I know that the
New Hampshire Department of Labor
already
enforces some of the items in this piece
of legislation where I support the
finance committee and vote
green
motion before its majority Committee
reported in expand to legislative and
House Bill 74 this is a division vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button it'll be opposed or press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
thank you
well Memphis president and opportunity
to vote house will attend state of the
vote
179 voting yay 204 voting a the motion
fails
representative Cahill moves ought to
pass
are you ready for the question
who requested a roll call
as that's that is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote
the motion before us is ought to pass on
House Bill 74. this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if your opposal press a red
button or any stations are open for 30
seconds
foreign
ER
ball members president had an
opportunity to vote household 10 state
of the vote
205 voting a 181 voting a
committee report of Auto passes adopted
joined a committee on finance to which
was referred House Bill 234 FN it's
relative to renewable energy credits
having considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolved that as inexpedient to
legislation of Dan Maguire for the
majority of the committee
minority at a committee having
considered the same but unable to agree
with the majority report the
recommendation to fill out a pass
representative Karen able for the
minority of the committee
chair recognizes representative McGee
thank you Mr Speaker
this bill repeals the statute that
allows utilities to take credit for
electricity produced by individual
customers who are net metered but who
have not signed up to claim their
renewable energy credits
this practice known as wreck sweeping
does two things that run counter to the
intent of the renewable energy credit or
Rec program number one it allows the
utilities to meet their obligation
without having done anything to support
clean energy Supply and number two the
credits the utilities apply to their
compliance obligation don't belong to
them and they're not required to notify
the customers that they're taking these
credits nor do they compensate the
individuals for the value of the wrecks
that they sweep
these two points together undermine the
value of Rex and depress the market
creating a vicious cycle rather than a
virtuous one
we've had testimony in committee that
this practice constitutes an illegal
taking of property a wreck has value
that the owner can do with as he sees
fit
this bill attempts to correct the flaw
in the Rex system to bring down costs
clearly recent efforts to curb Energy
Efficiency programs and hold Rec Rex
hostage has done nothing to prevent the
hundred and fifty percent electric rate
increase last year we cannot keep doing
the same thing and expecting a different
result
on February 23rd you heard and
considered hb234
the OTP vote was a tie 182 to 182 the
itl vote failed by six votes the motion
to reconsider passed by nine votes and
the OTP on reconsideration one by ten
votes
we voted to save this bill and then by a
wider margin we voted to pass the bill
which is only before you again today
because it was sent to a second
committee for which neither I nor the
committee can find any justification
you were informed in a crescendo in a
parliamentary inquiry on the 23rd that
this bill was opposed by the department
of energy and I've confirmed that the
doe takes no position on the
legislature's ability to remediate wreck
sweeping as a practice
so I ask you once again to pass this
bill so the value of renewable energy
credits program can be restored along
with its intent to be a lever for
lowering energy costs protecting our
wallets and paychecks thank you
do you recognize the representative Dan
Maguire
thank you Mr Speaker
this bill came to us
exactly as described we did not find
that there's any special Financial
aspect to it other than the fact that
the state is a consumer of electricity
like we all are
so what we're going to talk about is the
benefits or or detriment of the bill
itself
so what this bill does
is it
um prevents utilities from reimbursing
their customers for alternative energy
that those
um those customers create but don't uh
don't account for all right so we we
require
utilities to provide a certain fraction
of their energy from alternative means
in this case solar
and the mechanism that the utilities use
to prove that they're they're providing
a certain amount of solar
is quite complicated but essentially
what happens is solar producers get
certificates called Rex
and then they they sell those wrecks to
utilities utilities turn them in and say
aha we've created so much solar
well it turns out certain very small
solar producers don't bother to ask for
their wrecks because the process
involved is complicated Etc so they they
produce solar
but they don't ask for the proof that
that they have done so and so what we do
is we know that solar is out there
so we re we lower the requirement that
the utilities have
for proving how much solar they are they
are providing all right so and the the
amount of money involved is roughly
three million dollars a year
so that solar three million dollars
worth not of energy but three million
dollars worth of proof sort of
um is being produced by solar so the
solar is actually there the benefit for
it is going to customers
if this bill were to pass
um the the what the what the sponsor of
this bill would like is for that three
million dollars to be instead put into
the Energy Efficiency fund because what
normally would happen is the the
requirements for the utilities would be
higher right and so they would have to
go out and either buy wrecks from other
producers
or pay some kind of a fine and that fine
is what feeds the Energy Efficiency fund
all right the problem is that
the bills of the customers are being
credited by the three million dollars
the customers are paying three million
dollars less
than they would be otherwise if this
bill were to pass right but
that three million dollars won't
necessarily go into the Energy
Efficiency fund because the utilities
might just go out and buy wrecks from
other people so there's no fines
involved so there's no money going into
the Energy Efficiency fund so so the
three million dollars that the bills
that the consumers are paying less of
you know is saving
um are is for sure
and the amount that might go into the
Energy
Efficiency fund is speculative
all right so this is a this is a bad
Bill for that reason let's keep our
energy costs low I mean obviously three
million dollars is not a big number when
you talk about the value of all in all
electricity but it's something so let's
keep energy costs low and push the green
button thank you so remember yield to
questions yes I yes I'll take a question
remember yields
thank you Mr Speaker and thank you
representative for taking my question
would you agree with me that the the
so-called wrecks are basically Fiat
that's created by the state through the
RPS law and if that law were to be
changed so that the the RPS standards
were higher the wrecks would be worth
more if it was changed to make the
requirements lower the wrecks would be
worse less in fact if it was repealed
the wrecks would be worth nothing so
there's no illegal taking by the state
doing this
yes you're you're absolutely right the
the rec thing is and sort of artificial
mechanism created by law just to promote
solar thank you
a division has been requested members
take your seats
thank you
clear
the motion before us is the majority
committee report of in expedient to
legislator in House Bill 234 it's a
division vote chair recognizes
representative McWilliams for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that this bill will repeal the
Renewable Energy Credit scheme that is
currently being perpetrated on our small
energy producers some of them are our
constituents who have renewable energy
and are not getting the benefit of those
wrecks and those wrecks are in effect
being taken and further Mr Speaker if I
know that this bill would end a vicious
cycle of depressing the value of those
renewable energy credits and further Mr
Speaker if I know that this bill would
stop giving our money to out-of-state
corporations large companies that
provide energy that don't need this in
addition to our own utilities who also
don't need this and should be following
their own Rec requirements would I vote
red on this so a better motion may be
made thank you Mr Speaker
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that a grocery
coupon is a lot like a renewable energy
certificate in that it has no value
unless it's used or redeemed
and if I also know that you need to file
an application to create a renewable
energy certificate
and if you don't file it
that wreck does not exist
it's a phantom
and therefore it leaves nothing to be
swept up
and finally if I know that every
electricity rate payer pays for each of
these Phantom wrecks
would I now press the green button to
prevent the further sweeping of dollars
from our wallets thank you Mr Speaker
the motion before us is the majority
committee report of inexp mean to
legislator in House Bill 234 this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press a green button if you're opposed
or press a red button organizations are
open for 30 seconds
representative Peter Schmitz
while Memphis president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend
the state of the vote
193 voting yay 191 voting a committee
report is adopted
we have two announcements before lunch
representative sealig
selig
and representative goalie is up next
thank you thank you Mr Speaker those of
us who are Jewish or supporters of the
Jewish Community want to invite you to
share in a number of Passover themed
treats that we have out in the ante room
please try to be neat as you eat things
and we also wish everyone a Happy
Passover a meaningful Ramadan and for
those of you who are celebrating this
weekend happy Easter and if none of
those apply to you just a lovely day
foreign
goalie thank you Mr Speaker members of
the legislative Sportsman's caucus and
those wanting to learn a little more
about the caucus are invited to lunch
over at the upper Walker house members
of fish and game will be there as well
as members of the national Wild Turkey
Federation
we're in recess until 1 30 1 30.
foreign
the committee on finance Detroit
Hospital 250 FN not relative to
accidental death benefit payable to
group 2 member have been considered the
same report the same with the following
Amendment and recommendation of the bill
on a passport Amendment
so Dan McGuire for the committee
the amendment is
10458 printed in house record 18 page
30.
are you ready for the question on
Amendment all those in favor say aye
it was a close day the United cabinet
amendment is adopted goes on second
reading open to further Amendment
and
representative
we do off its floor Amendment 1319
it was recognized to speak to his
Amendment
thank you thank you Mr Speaker
members of the house it's another long
day
and I guess I'm glad to be first up
after lunch rather than last up before
lunch
it's been 22 years since I've been to
the well and it still does feel like the
first time
so I still still get right to the point
I rise in support of ought to pass on
floor Amendment 1319 H which is exactly
like the amendment we just passed with a
minor correction this amendment allows
the funding for these accidental line of
duty death claims to be drawn from the
general fund
so I rise in support of this amendment
and I also rise in support of our Fire
EMS and police First Responders and more
importantly for the loved ones they
leave behind
following a tragic line of duty
accidental death
so I've been in emergency medical
services for 32 years and as of last
Saturday 25 of those years as a
paramedic
I remember working an ambulance on
September 11 2001 a little after eight
in the morning being called back to base
in Nashua New Hampshire and all the
events
the following events of that horrible
day
I know this house wants to support this
employee population in our state's
ability
to recruit more
into this sometimes dangerous profession
this amendment will help us do exactly
that
keeping the small cost of the future
claims from being downshifted to the
towns
allowing them to be drawn from the
general fund
it simply adds language to the original
finance committee Amendment the one we
just passed making it possible to fund
the costs from the state general funds
instead of passing it on to the towns
based on the policy decision made here
so if you support our First Responders
and all of our state employees families
in the event of an accidental death and
you also oppose unfunded mandates
please support passing this amendment
thank you colleagues and thank you Mr
Speaker
the motion before us the question before
us is on on the amendment 1319 are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
there's opposed name the eyes have it
and the floor amendment is adopted
representative Senator natasto has asked
for a roll call vote is sufficiently
seconded this will be a roll call vote
vote on the bill
members take your seats
the motion before us is ought to pass as
amended on House Bill 250. this is going
to be a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
your opposed will press a red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
the screen on the wall over here facing
the capitol I mean facing the front is
out of order so depend on the other
three
O'Brien
McKenzie
and representative
foreign
[Music]
opportunity to vote house will
attendance state of the vote
328 voting yay 53 voting a
Committee reported the doctor
committee on finance to which was
deferred House Bill 330
FNA that's relative to National guide
Recruitment and Center Program in its
funding and rulemaking considered the
same report the same with the
recommendation of the bill ought to pass
and Ken Wilder for the committee motion
before it says ought to pass are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
close May
you always have it and the committee
report is adopted
committee on finance to which was
referred House Bill 337 FM act relative
to direct any Office Professional
licensure and certification to provide
notice of public meetings an opportunity
for comment from the public having
considered the same report the same
with the recommendation to build on a
pass except Dan McGuire for the
committee representative
San Andreas requested a roll call with a
sufficiently seconded this will be a
roll call vote
all members should be in their seats
foreign
[Music]
motion before us is ought to pass on
House Bill 337 FN this is a roll call
vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed or press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
[Music]
representative Davis
well member as president had an
opportunity to vote also attend the
state of the road
387 voting yay zero voting a committee
reporters adoption
I'll also be in order
committee on finance to which was
referred House Bill 364 FN act relative
to transportation for students attending
Career and Technical Education Centers
considered the same report the same with
the recommendation of the bill ought to
pass Senator Mary Heath for the
committee
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
Ms May the eyes have it and the
committee report is adopted
enjoy the committee on finance the which
was referred House Bill 430 FM local an
act relative to applications for the
education Freedom accounts program
having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolve that is inexpedient
to legislate Senator Ken Weiler for the
majority of the committee
the minority of the committee have been
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority Report with a
recommendation to Bill ought to pass for
Senator Mary Heath for the minority of
the committee chair recognizes
representative Harkin Phillips
thank you Mr Speaker
colleagues I rise today to speak against
the motion of itl of HB 430. relative to
applications for Education Freedom
accounts program because this
legislation is fair and fiscally prudent
hb30 modifies one sentence and the
existing EFA statute to limit applicants
to one who is currently attending a New
Hampshire Public School including a
chartered public school for a minimum of
one year or who is entering kindergarten
or first grade
first this legislation is fair because
the language will honor the original
intent of EFA accounts and the 2020
hearings the public was told the purpose
of esa's were to provide an alternative
when a public school was unable to meet
the child's particular educational needs
efas represent an alternative a choice
this legislation is fair because it puts
the state back on track by making sure
the majority of kids taking advantage of
the program have actually experienced
those public schools for at least a year
and are choosing to take their EFA Grant
to their particular educational needs
outside of their Public School District
according to the Department of Education
of approximately the 3200 students
currently enrolled in the EFA program
only about a hundred students made the
actual choice to leave their Public
School the vast majority about 89
percent of the EFA students have never
experienced a public education but
rather were already enrolled in and
paying for their home school or a
private religious school as the program
currently exists this 89 percent of EFA
enrollees were making a different kind
of choice
the choice to continue paying out of
pocket for their own education or the
choice to get the state to help in
paying for part of the education
this legislation is fair because it will
restore the program to its intended
purpose and eliminate the windfall so
that the choice truly is being made to
seek an alternative to New Hampshire
public education
second this legislation is fiscally
prudent
because it would rain in the program's
runaway spending simple math tells us
that if 89 of the current 15.2 million
dollar per year EFA program is suddenly
ineligible then we can expect
significant multi-million dollar savings
to the state those students falling out
of the program will either go back to
paying for their home school private or
religious educations without state
substancy state subsidies or they will
enroll in their local or public school
districts
of the Department of Education is if the
Department of Education is correct of
the majority of the students enrolling
in a public school 95 percent will
enroll with a non-access swept community
resulting in a net neutral result to the
state in some this legislation is
fiscally prudent because we can expect
to save millions of dollars in total EFA
spending unless there obviously be less
pressure on the education trust fund
we know that this legislation is
fiscally print as well because it's
going to help relieve pressure on Town
and City governments in raising their
local property taxes but don't take my
word for it
forbes.com has written school funding
was reduced by the cost of the voucher
but School expenses were reduced by zero
dollars
so that local tax base or taxpayers are
left to choose between cutting services
and raising taxes
that's the quote I'll say that again
local taxpayers are choosing between
cutting Public School services or
raising taxes it's not exactly the
choice that New Hampshire was offered if
the initial EFA program was introduced
if this fiscally responsible legislation
passes then the public school districts
will be less likely to be forced to make
the tough decision of cutting services
or raising local property taxes and we
can all expect less pressure
for our local tax rates this legislation
is clearly a win for all in New
Hampshire colleagues I look around the
room and I know that fairness and fiscal
responsibility are two values that we
all can Embrace regardless of the side
of the political aisle we sit on please
join me in honoring this Chambers
February 23rd vote of 176 to 168 for HB
430. by now voting no on the Motions of
itl so that another motion can be made
thank you Mr Speaker and I requested
division vote
the Zoomer video to questions
no member does not yield chair recognize
representative Weiler
thank you Mr Speaker
I view House Bill 430 as an unnecessary
roadblock to parental choice
why require
every student to go to school for a year
in a public school if there's already
been an older sibling that the parents
have determined
that this was not what they wanted for
their children they could make the
choice for an older child why do this
this would make the younger child have
to go
even though the parents didn't approve
of the school
or if someone moved from somewhere else
where they already had some relationship
with a a charter school or some other
school that they wanted to send their
child to why would they why should they
be required to send this child
to a public school for a year
that's an unnecessary roadblock and it
doesn't recognize some of the costs
we are also recognizing that the public
schools are spending around twenty
thousand dollars per pupil
parents are choosing an option that's
about five thousand dollars
and yet they're more satisfied with it
so yes there's a choice the public
school should need to be reducing as
they are anyway because of the decline
in enrollment
so this is just the same thing that's
going on whether the student goes to
uh on different school or whether the
enrollment enrollment declines they
should be adjusting for that without
claiming they're losing a lot of money
and we're costing them money we're
actually educating the education Freedom
accounts for a lot less money so let's
recognize that let's support parental
Choice let's support what's best for the
child and there are many families that
will divide their children one may be in
a different school and the others may be
in the in the public school depends on
what works best for their child why do
we put roadblocks please support the
congression
remember yield a question
yes member yields
of fidelity
thank you Mr speaker thank you
representative
um we've heard that the bill requires a
student to be in public school for a
year but when I was reading the bill the
definition of a child who is eligible
says you just have to be eligible to
attend a public school I'm confused can
you explain how this bill works
it puts a requirement to have that child
go to the public school even though
they're eligible for something else so
it could be debatable and it could
depend on how it's interpreted but I
think the intent is to make it more
difficult to for Education freedom
the Marshall before us is inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill 430
representative Senator natasto has
requested a roll call it is sufficiently
seconded this will be a roll call vote
members take your seats
thank you
we're
the motion before is the majority
committee report of inexpension to
legislator and House Bill 430 this is a
roll-call vote
the chair recognizes Kate Murray for a
parliamentary inquiry
Mr Speaker if I know that the education
Freedom accounts are created to provide
an alternative to students who find
their public school is unable to meet
their particular needs and if I find
that every child is an individual and
for some of those children the public
school does meet those needs and if I
also know that this bill reinforces the
intent and honors the intent of the
original bill which passed this house on
February 23rd when I now press the red
button to overturn the itl
recommendations so that another motion
may be made that reflects the original
intent of the program and the will of
this body thank you Mr Speaker
do you recognize rep level of his lad
for a parliamentary inquiry
acquire students students be in New
Hampshire public school before getting
an EFA account but
if I also know that the definition for
an eligible student remains anyone
eligible to enroll in a public school
and lastly if I know this is yet another
attempt to undermine another very
successful school choice program
would I then press the green button to
itl this Bill thank you the motion
before is the majority committee report
of index being to legislate and House
Bill 430 this is a roll call vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button
all members president had an opportunity
to vote household 10 state of the vote
194 voting yay 192 voting 80 committee
reporters adopted
representative Hicks and seaworth
declared a conflict of interest and did
not participate
committee on finance to which those
referred House Bill 492 FN enact
requiring Department of Education to
provide the House and Senate standing
committee's responsible for Education
with copies of the laws and rules
relative to education considered the
same report the same in the
recommendation the bill ought to pass
Senator Mary Heath for the committee
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye Enterprise nay you guys
have it and committee report is adopted
majority committee on finance to which
those referred House Bill 504 FN act
relative to the adult parole board and
making an appropriation therefore having
considered the same report the same with
the recommendations to Bill ought to
pass is David Hewitt for the majority of
the committee
minority of the committee have been
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
following Amendment the recommendation
of Bill ought to pass with Amendment
Senator J.R hall for the minority of the
committee
the motion before us is the
recommendation of ought to pass are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye both opposed A
the eyes have it and the committee
report is adopted
majority of the committee on finance the
which was referred House Bill 534 FNA an
act relative to water assistance for
natural disasters having considered the
same report the same with the following
resolution resolve that is inexpeding to
legislate
president of Dan McGuire for the
majority of the committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
recommendation Bill ought to pass from
Senator Mary Harkin Phillips with a
minority of the committee chair
recognized representative Harkin
Phillips
foreign
thank you Mr Speaker
colleagues I Rise Against the motion of
itl of HB 534 because this bipartisan
legislation supported by the Des and the
New Hampshire Municipal Association
reflects good policy that will improve
the lives of the most needy Granite
Staters with when a natural disaster
strikes and they need to restore access
to clean drinking water for their
private well
HB 534 Builds on an existing program but
these temporary program funds are
running dry
in 2020 New Hampshire drinking water and
groundwater advisory commission began
its work administering a temporary
emergency trust fund with 3.2 million
dollars part of this trust fund is
earmarked for Community water system
assistance and 1.5 million dollars was
earmarked for private well assistance to
low-income homeowners
to date 147 processed States have
received emergency water access after
natural disasters we know the program is
working because the trust funds balance
is now at four hundred thousand and
there's no plan to replenish it so after
the three years of this good work by the
commission they recommend a permanent
dedicated fund be established to meet
projected future needs of natural
disaster victims this bill establishes
that permanent dedicated non-lapsing
fund called the water assistance for
natural disasters fund and it
appropriates 2.5 million dollars in both
years of the biennium for the purpose of
replacing repairing and treating private
drinking water sources in the event of a
natural disaster for the state's most
economically disadvantaged homeowners
critics will argue that this bill gives
broad rulemaking authority to the Des in
violation of house rules but we know the
commissions has existing applicant
eligibility guidelines that are based in
HUD income limits particular to New
Hampshire's medium household income
qualifications and definitions we also
know that the commission's guidelines
require applicants to document their
financial need and to demonstrate that
they've exhausted all other available
funding sources this bill authorizes Des
to create application and acceptance
criteria and applicable rules for
administering the new fund using
existing commission guidelines so that
there's a continuity of the temporary
program and it moves forward to the
permanent program
critics will also argue that the build
creates a fund that already exists for a
problem that is addressed by FEMA
declarations and our rainy day funds
however there's a gap
please understand on the one hand there
are large-scale natural disasters or
FEMA declarations come Federal funding
and New Hampshire rainy day funds swoop
into assist
but on the other hand there are small
case droughts and floods where there are
families in need but there's no
financial assistance to come from the
state the fed or our municipalities and
don't forget that private property
insurance Force measure Clauses prevents
assistance to these people this
legislation fills that Gap
let's face the facts our state is in the
fourth year of a drought
and those conditions while they're
lessening
we know we must be prepared to meet the
future
I call your attention to the real
Financial concerns that the entire state
will face over time private wells in the
rural areas of our state will run dry
and the neediest families cannot pay to
have their world's restored then they're
going to be forced to migrate to more
urbanized settings
those rural property values are going to
plummet
and when those Urban Street pipes need
to expand it's going to cost far more in
time and resources to grow and maintain
those large-scale projects that five
million dollar that this bill proposes
that allocation is a far cheaper
Financial commitment than the cost of
reversing economically depressed rural
areas and keeping Pace with ever
increasing Urban infrastructure needs
finally HB 534 is one important piece of
the puzzle that will help us solve our
housing stock and affordability crisis
which we all know is plaguing our state
as a legislature with a special
committee on housing we recognize
something must be done at the state
level to ameliorate this crisis
HB 534
will keep our most vulnerable people in
their homes longer
imagine losing your well after a natural
disaster and being forced to move out
with almost nowhere in the state to go
let's do our part and help increase well
access so that our poorest community
members only have to deal with one
crisis at a time
for these reasons I hope you'll join me
in supporting this legislation and
overturning the itl motion
um so that another motion may be made
thank you Mr Speaker and I do request a
division vote
do you recognize representative Dan
Maguire
thank you Mr Speaker this bill is very
well intentioned but it has problems
both in concept and in execution
first of all the concept so this bill
creates a special purpose fund to
um
give out money in the case of
drinking water problems caused by a
natural disaster
the problem is when a natural disaster
occurs
um it can be of any kind not just one
that happens to affect drinking water we
could have a natural disaster that
washes out roads or Bridges or effects
sewer systems or electricity or what
have you right and so what do we do to
prepare for natural disasters is we have
a general purpose fund it's called the
rainy day fund and so when something
unusual happens like a natural disaster
a big lawsuit or something like that we
have general purpose dollars put aside
to take care of it
this bill proposes that for the case of
a natural disaster that affects drinking
water specifically we have a fund of
five million dollars for that
well what if the natural disaster does
something else right it's silly to have
this five million dollars somehow in a
special kind of an account rather than
just boosting the rainy day fund which
can handle any kind of a disaster or any
kind of a problem
secondly the way the bill is written
so the we have a house rule house rule
45d which tells us not to pass any
legislation that has broad rulemaking
Authority
broad rule banking Authority means that
we just tell an agency
here's our goal you go figure out how to
do it and how much you're going to spend
on it and all that sort of thing
so this bill does not specify what is a
natural disaster it doesn't specify who
is eligible to apply for funds it
doesn't specify whether these are grants
or loans
it doesn't specify the criteria by which
money is dispersed you know are we
paying for a hundred percent of the
problem or 50 of the problem or ten
percent of the problem is it somehow
matching money none of that is in the
bill and and in particular What's worst
is the bill says that Des May charge
their expenses to the fund
but there are absolutely no limits on
that right it's not like 10 percent of
the disbursements can be used for
expenses or something like that it just
says charge your expenses to the fund so
this is the very definition of broad
rule making Authority and
um you know it's there's there's good
intentions
um we were I believe formally in a
drought we are not currently in a
drought and so there are better ways to
accomplish the same task thank you Mr
Speaker
representative Senator was requested a
roll call it is officially seconded this
will be a roll call vote
the motion before us is the majority
committee report of inexperienced
legislative House Bill 534 this is a
roll call vote care recognizes
representative Bill Boyd for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that establishing a five
million dollar non-lapsing water
assistance for natural disaster fund
administered by the Department of
Environmental Services would help keep
the most economically vulnerable granted
Staters
to replace repair and treat their
private drinking sources in event of a
natural disaster
and Mr Speaker if I further know that
slow-moving natural natural disasters
like droughts and small-scale flooding
may not trigger FEMA declarations and
that Associated Federal funding for this
legislation would fill the policy Gap to
help economically vulnerable homeowners
gain access to clean drinking water when
they're well strung run dry
and lastly Mr Speaker if I further know
that providing financial assistance to
restore dry Wells has a strong return on
investment because it keeps New
Hampshire's most vulnerable homeowners
in their homes increases property values
and prevents the exacerbation of our
affordable housing crisis then Mr
Speaker would I now press the red button
against inexpedient to legislate so that
another motion may be made thank you Mr
Speaker
do you recognizes representative
Campbell is for a parliamentary inquiry
cameras
chair recognize representative Dan
McGuire for a parliamentary inquiry I
apologize uh thank you Mr Speaker
if I know that this bill is well
intentioned but flawed and if I know
that it has problems both in concept and
in execution if I know that it has broad
rulemaking Authority would I now press
the green button thank you Mr Speaker
motion before us is the majority commit
a report of inexperience of legislative
and House Bill 534 this is a roll call
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed press the
red button voting stations are open for
30 seconds
[Music]
all members president an opportunity to
vote house will tend to stay to
Louisville
191 voting yay 196 voting a the
committee report of itl fails
representative haken Phillips moves
ought to pass
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
the eyes have it 196 to 191.
committee on finance to which was
referred House Bill 576 FNA local an act
relative to administration of a
commercial property assessed cleaning
sea PACE program in a Clean Energy
Efficiency and clean energy District
have been considered the same report the
same with the following Amendment and
the recommendation bill on a password
Amendment Senator Joe Sweeney for the
committee
the amendment is
0692h President house record 18 Pages
31-32 ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say aye Mr
suppose they you guys have it and the
committee amendment is adopted the
motion before us now is ought to pass
with Amendment are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
his name your eyes have it and the
committee report is adopted
majority of the committee on finance to
which was referred House Bill 626 FN
enact requiring the Department of
Education to administer the education
Freedom account consider the same report
the same with the following resolution
result that is inexpected to legislate
representative Ken Weiler for the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee have been
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority
Report with the recommendation of the
bill ought to pass Senator Mary heat for
the minority at a committee chair
recognizes representative luno
thank you very much Mr Speaker
House Bill 626 would require the New
Hampshire Department of Education to
administer the education Freedom account
program that's right HB 626 would have
the department that's currently
responsible for over 165 000 New
Hampshire students to administer a
program that serves approximately 3 200
students
it would cost taxpayers less than the 10
percent being charged now by the
contractor to manage the program
it would be more responsible because the
department would know how tax dollars
are actually being spent
and it would be accountable to the
voters all good things
we got it right when we when we all
voted to pass this bill back in February
let's overturn the ITIL motion now so
that we can pass this bill again thank
you Mr Speaker and I requested division
thank you Mr Speaker you might be
surprised to know the Department of
Education is already supervising and
managing this program
they manage the contract and they're
putting out an RFP this month to see if
there are other providers there's a
little catch in this you have to be
approved by RSA
77r don't ask me
there was only one vendor in the state
of New Hampshire that had that approval
and that's the current vendor that we're
using
the current vendor has processed forty
thousand
uh orders on this on this program it's
about 10 orders per student because
basically what's happening students are
unbundling their education the parents
are so they might have a tutor for this
and a textbook for that and an online
course for this so it's unbundling to
the needs of the student
they have the vendor has 12 full-time
employees to administer this the 5000
initial applications cooked down to the
3200 you've heard mentioned several
times
they have to re-register every year so
come September everybody's at zero they
got to start all over again so this is
not something that somebody in the
department of education is going to do
on a part-time basis this is a lot of
work and the vendor is being supervised
by the Department of Education so please
press the green button for itl thank you
motion before us majority committed
report of inexpensive legislative House
Bill 626 representative Senator natasto
has requested a roll call in a
sufficiently seconded so this will be a
roll call vote members take your seats
thank you
the motion before its majority committee
report of index being to legislator and
House Bill 626
house will be in order
this is a roll call vote chair
recognizes representative Kate Murray
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that this bill
moves the oversight of the freedom
education Freedom accounts to our own
Department of Education and what
oversight there may be now I think can
be further enhanced by having it
actually housed in our Department of
Education
and if I know that this is a modest
responsible proposal which will provide
better
fiscal oversight and an increased
transport transparency and better local
management that can what be found by an
out-of-state private Enterprise and that
the Department of Education by having
the oversight of this program housed
within its own Chambers is able to Prov
is able to do an RFP is able to reach
out in a way that's appropriate to them
for less money than what apparently we
are paying now
and if I know this bill passed the Full
House in February would I now press the
red button to overturn the itl
recommendation so another motion may be
paid made that reflects the will of this
house as demonstrated in past February
thank you Mr Speaker
do you recognize representative Weiler
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know that the success
of the education Freedom account is
basically due to the present vendor
who has really gone out of her way to
recruit funds and to recruit people and
if I further know that when this there's
a short window when all these
applications come in requiring sometimes
10 hour days six days a week which would
not be easily adaptable to the education
department who would probably want
people year round for that rush time
when they really don't need them the
rest of the time so knowing that this
program is successful that it has been
supervised and that it's working the way
it is because of the way we have it set
up let's not allow this attack on it
press the green button
motion before us majority committee
report of inexperiod to legislate on
House Bill 626 this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button of your opposed or press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
thank you
[Music]
all members president have an
opportunity to vote house will attend
the state of the vote
195 to 194.
the speaker did vote to break the tie
so the committee report is adopted
the house will be in order
Committee on Public Works and highways
to which was referred House Bill 25A
Knack making Appropriations for Capital
Improvements considered the same report
the same with the following Amendment
the recommendation that bill ought to
pass with Amendment Senator Mark
McConkey for the committee
the amendment is is one one zero one H
printed in house record 18 Pages 16
through 30. you ready for the question
on the amendment all those in favor say
aye and I suppose nay the eyes have it
and the amendment is adopted
those on second reading open to further
Amendment representative Kaczynski
offers floor Amendment 1177
and is recognized to speak
to his Amendment
thank you Mr Speaker colleagues Public
Works put forward a very generous
Capital Improvements budget and
this amendment
attempts to delete 750
000 subsidy to two privately owned
railroads
the cause county line is scheduled to
get 500 000 in the Carroll in Stratford
County 250
000.
regardless of your opinion of rail in
New Hampshire this is not passenger rail
This is highly profitable Freight rail
they've experienced record profits in
the last several years
the northern route in Columbus County is
owned by CX CSX railroad number three in
the United States in profits in 2022
they had a 14.9 billion dollar revenue
and net earnings of one of 4.17 billion
a 28.05 profit margin
Stratford County H nhn Railroad
is owned by Boston sand and gravel who
also owns ospi Aggregates and Ossipee in
Rochester Manchester sand and gravel and
several other companies
it's a multi-million dollar
Massachusetts business
and this is a private transportation
system for their sand to go from Ossipee
to Boston five days a week
they testified in committee
to how low the costs were using rail
versus truck
wealthy late 19th century industrialists
were called robber barons
the carnegies The Rockefellers the
Vanderbilts
should we be transferring constituent
money to 21st century robber barons
a recent piece by Wall Street journals
Andy Kessler is entitled Kickback
capitalism
and it tells of the government throwing
your money at favored constituents the
economic leak
and this is a prime example
we were told that this is going on for
20 years
well if there was a need at some time I
certainly don't see it now
we're told that rail keeps the trucks
off the New Hampshire roads and that's
true
and I don't see any reason that that
would change CSX railroad is making too
high of a profit in Boston sand and
gravel saves too much money using that
system
said that we that they pay to use the
tracks and the rights away and they
could well afford to do that and should
it said that we subsidize bus lines and
airports the difference being this is
Freight not people
the bottom line is Freight rail is
hugely profitable it doesn't need
subsidies
this should not be a partisan issue we
are all responsible for spending
taxpayer money carefully
how can you justify transferring your
constituents money to 21st century
robber barons
many legitimate needs are addressed in
this capital budget
private rate private Freight rail
subsidies is not one of them
this amendment simply deletes the 750
000 subsidy
please join me in voting for this
amendment Mr Speaker I request the
division vote thank you
chair recognize representative McConkey
thank you Mr Speaker
the 750 thousand dollars that the good
member asked to remove from our 137
million dollar
capital budget is without Merit in my
opinion
our transportation commissioner is
authorized to contract for the
rebuilding of any properties either Pub
publicly or privately owned
the commissioner is hereby authorized to
spend any sums authorized for such a
project as well as any other available
funds for the modernization and
rebuilding of rail properties
the commissioner is also authorized to
do such maintenance on any real
properties as appears necessary for the
public interest
for decades the state through the
capital budget process has supported
public private Enterprises to date they
include private airport owners Transit
bus line operators and yes private rail
owners
the two private rail owners for the rep
that the representative seeks to remove
their appropriation operate 90 miles of
track in New Hampshire
one of those lines is a Saint Lawrence
and is used by other railroad owners on
a continuous basis sending Freight to
and from our state in the other North
Coast sends San from Ossipee to Boston
in backloads propane to Eastern
propane's bulk farm in Rochester
both rail operators pay a rail tax to
the towns they operate in to the state
and pay additional property taxes for
the property and buildings that support
their operations
in the past 10 years they have
collectively paid
more than nine hundred thousand dollars
in rail tax
to be clear the capital funding provided
to these two operators is not without
strings
one the private rail owners must match
the state award for dollar for dollar
the rail company must identify the
section of rail ties or Road bed that
will be replaced in the state rail
division will oversee that construction
finally the state will record a lien on
that section of rail for a period of 10
years to be assured our investment stays
in place
it goes out it goes without saying that
Freight being transported on those rails
eliminates thousands of heavy trucks off
our highways annually
sparing our roads and bridges from
deterioration and further protecting our
air quality
the representative from Rochester voiced
his objections at length at our public
hearing and during the executive session
on House Bill 25 but his objections were
not well supported by our committee
I humbly request that you reject this
amendment keep HB 25 as amended intact
impress the red button thank you for
your time the motion before us is the
Kaczynski four Amendment 1177 a division
has been requested members take your
seats this will be a division vote
the motion before us is the Kaczynski
four Amendment 1177 this is a division
vote
the chair recognizes representative
Kaczynski for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that Freight rail is one of the
most profitable businesses in the United
States
and if I know that we have no business
transferring 750 000 of taxpayer money
to 21st century robber barons
and if I also know that Freight rail
will continue to flourish even with the
adoption of this amendment
would I now press the green button to
end the blatant example of Kickback
capitalism thank you Mr Speaker
Geo recognize representative Claudio for
parliamentary inquiry
hey thank you Mr Speaker if I know that
the good representative from Rochester
attempted to remove this funding in the
committee but found little traction
and if I know in the light of the recent
train Realty railment near the Ohio
Pennsylvania state line that it is
better to have well-maintained rail
systems than not would I now press the
red button to defeat this four Amendment
thank you Mr Speaker
the motion before us is the Kaczynski
floor Amendment 1177 to house bill 125.
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed to press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
all members president an opportunity to
vote house will tend to save the vote
120 voting yay 267 voting a the floor
Amendment fails motion before us now
representative Leachman declared a
conflict and did not vote on the
amendment
the motion before us now was ought to
pass as amended are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
the eyes have it and committee report is
adopted
majority house will be in order
majority committee on ways it means to
which was deferred House Bill 639 FNA
relative to the legalization regulation
of cannabis and making appropriation
therefore having considered the same
report the same with the following
Amendment and the recommendation that
the bill ought to pass with Amendment
representative Waldo spillsbury
for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same report the same
being unable to agree with the majority
Report with the recommendation of Bill
ought to pass and since Sally fellows
for the minority of the committee
the amendment is one two three one-h
printed in house record 18 pages 32-43
the chair recognize the representative
of all me
it's a long second because I'm speaking
about the bill well
the motion before us is the amendment
one two three eight h
are you ready for the question all those
are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say aye
I suppose nay the eyes have it and the
amendment is adopted
now the chair recognizes representative
balmy
as ought to pass with Amendment
thank you Mr Pete speaker I apologize we
didn't quite get our ducks in order
on about a century ago cannabis was
wrongly classified as a drug as
dangerous as heroin
it is less addictive than the liquor
that we sell for our profit
all of our neighboring states have
legalized adult cannabis use
manufacturing and sales they regulate
potency and quality labeling and
education we do not
yet most of our citizens live with an
easy distance of illegal cannabis store
Point number one aren't we safer in the
long run if we do also regulate cannabis
use and work to protect against its
abuse
Point number two we intend to undercut
the price of legal cannabis in this
region and to try to become the first
state to wipe out the black market
Point number three we have too many
citizens that would have become assets
to our state and our communities
but whose life chances were cut short
because they were convicted of
possession or sale of cannabis
criminal records stopped them from
gainful employment and stable home lives
this bill ends future tragedies
please listen carefully to my esteemed
colleagues description of the committee
Amendment but of the the changes that we
had made and vote for that vote for the
Bill thank you very much
do you recognize representative
spilsbury
thank you Mr Speaker
I'm going to avoid getting deep in the
weed
on
on second committee referral Ways and
Means accepted the broad policy
formulation adopted by this chamber in
February and limited its review to
matters of taxes revenues fees and
funding
it was the view of ways and means that
if the policy of New Hampshire
is to end its Regional isolation
and allow a nascent private Enterprise
and cannabis products to develop legally
then we should optimize the newborn
economic sector's potential to succeed
if our new state statute poses excessive
barriers
we may be less likely to achieve
important public policy purposes that
include driving out the black market
driving out adulterated product
and raising new state funds that can be
directed to important interests of the
state such as education funding
unfunded retirement system liabilities
and substance abuse problems
with this philosophy in mind the
committee's amendment
has improved
the bill in four important ways
we've reshaped it as an excise tax at
the wholesale level
set at 12 and a half percent
deliberately intending
that all the aspects of different
product are basically baked into the
Brownie and they and they are taxed in
the final form
at a competitive rate that will help the
business get established
we changed the allocation of State funds
from one
that steered the funds almost entirely
to the retirement liabilities
and we reapportioned them so that 50
percent will go to reduce the burden of
the swept tax on real property
30 percent to allay the unfunded
retirement liabilities
and the remaining 20 percent to targeted
programs of safety agencies and the
Department of Health and Human Services
we eliminated some exorbitant
application and setup fees in order to
remove barriers to entry
and we reset the Appropriations so that
as you would in a startup
entrepreneurial
um
business The Upfront costs are funded by
the state
and then we'll be reimbursed once the
Enterprise is going
the estimates for tax revenues
are that we're likely to see negligible
amount in the first two years
escalating rat dramatically to 35
million dollars in FY 26 70 million
dollars in FY 27 and 105 million dollars
in FY 28.
this is exactly the dramatic growth that
we want to encourage and enable
so Ways and Means has taken a very good
bill and made it better
and I ask you to support
otpa
motion before us is ought to pass with
Amendment
who requested the Roll Call
it is sufficiently second this will be a
roll call vote
also be in order
the motion before us is ought to pass on
amend with Amendment on House Bill 639
FNA this is a roll call vote
the chair recognized representative
spilsbury for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker
if I know that the time is long past due
to allow a legal private Enterprise in
cannabis and cannabis products to
develop successfully in the state of New
Hampshire subject to appropriate
regulation and Taxation would I now
press the green button to support the
otpa motion thank you Mr Speaker
the motion before it's a lot of paths
with Amendment this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed or press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
fall members president had an
opportunity to vote house will tend to
stay to the vote
272 voting yay 109 voting a the
committee report is adopted the senator
Beth Richard declared a conflict of
interest and did not participate
we now want bills removed from consent
committee on financed which was referred
House Bill 269 FN enact relative to
limiting The Authority of New Hampshire
delegates to policy making conventions
having considered the same report the
same the following Amendment a
recommendation of the bill ought to pass
with Amendment
representative Joe Sweeney for the
committee
the amendment is zero seven five two h
inted in house record 18 page 30. are
you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the committee
amendment is adopted
the chair recognizes representative
Kerry
good afternoon Mr Speaker and honored
colleagues I rise in opposition of the
committee ought to pass
for three reasons
first of all
I understand the frustration that we
have with our federal government
and I understand the want of some for
term limits and spending limits
but I do not believe opening up our
constitution is the way to resolve these
problems there are other ways
secondly
we don't have term limits ourselves and
before we begin mandating them for
others we should think about it for
ourselves because quite frankly many of
you in this room with whom I serve might
not be here if we limited ourselves
finally
the voters hold the authority to limit
our terms
to vote on what is spent
and we need to honor our Constitution
and leave it alone
thank you
as a member of yield the questions sure
I'm assuming that's a yes I thank the
member Fielding is it fair to say this
is a very similar Bill to the other two
Article 5 constitutional conventions
this body has already defeated
yes it's very similar to many
Constitutional Convention bills we have
already defeated and no disrespect to
those who worked hard on these bills
this one is a little like putting the
cart before the horse thank you
recognize representative Dan Maguire
thank you very much Mr Speaker
um I'm afraid I think that the last
statement here was incorrect so this
bill came to us from the state and
federal Relations Committee it
previously was voted by everyone in this
house on consent all we did in the
finance committee was look at the dollar
amounts in the bill it included a
hundred dollar per diem for legislative
members participating in such
conventions we decided that was
inappropriate and we removed that that's
what you just did with the amendment the
bill itself is totally unlike the
resolutions that were previously
proposed to call for such a convention
this bill only says what would happen
uh if such a convention was called in
the sense that who would go and how
would they be chosen and things like
that so this is prospective legislation
that I don't think has much effect so
passing it or not passing it probably
doesn't make much of a difference but it
is completely different from the
previous such bills about Article 5
conventions which were specifically
calling for such conventions this has
nothing to do with any particular
you know the type of convention or
content of convention or anything like
that it's strictly about
procedure who would go how would they be
chosen that sort of thing thank you Mr
Speaker
motion before us is ought to pass is
amended on House Bill 269.
are you ready for the question
a division has been requested members
take your seats
thank you
what's that
the motion before this ought to pass is
amended on House Bill 269 this is a
division vote
which I recognizer representative Erin
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker
if I know that this body recently
rejected hcr1 and hcr4 the convention of
states and term limits applications
asking Congress to call a convention and
if I also know that HB 269 is just
another sales pitch for those rejected
applications and if I further know Mr
Speaker that delegate bills have nothing
to do with selecting and controlling
delegates to an article 5 convention and
everything to do with securing votes on
those applications and lastly Mr Speaker
if I know that convention delegates as
Sovereign representatives of the people
have the inherent right to alter or to
abolish our form of government or write
a new constitution as expressed by the
Declaration of Independence paragraph
two and that they have more power than
State legislatures and Congress combined
making it such that no one or no one
legislative bill or state law has power
over the delegates making delegate bills
like this useless for their stated
purpose would I then Mr Speaker press
the red button to vote to overturn the
OTP motion and keep these Article 5
convention applications out of New
Hampshire law and allow another motion
to be made thank you Mr Speaker
recognize representative McGuire Dan
Dan McGuire for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that this is simply prospective
legislation would I now push the green
button to support the unanimous work of
the state and federal Relations
Committee when they studied this policy
and put it on consent thank you
the motion before it sought to pass as
amended on House Bill 269 the state
division vote if you're in Fayetteville
press the green button your opposed to
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
[Music]
all members president opportunity to
vote house will attendance state of the
vote
202 voting a 183 voting a committee
report is adopted
continue
committee on ways and means to which was
referred house
House Bill 445 FM act relatively
operational funds of oplc having
considered the same report the same with
the following Amendment the
recommendation of the bill ought to pass
with Amendment so Jordan uler for the
committee
so I recognizes representative Carol
McGuire for a motion
Mr Speaker I'd like to move to table
House Bill 445 and I like the vision
vote
the motion before us is the table house
bill 445.
FN are you ready for the question
the motion before
oh a division has been requested by
representative McGuire this will be a
division vote members take your seats
having fun
the motion before us is the table House
Bill 445 FN this is a division vote
chair recognizes representative Carol
McGuire for parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that this
section of law has appeared in at least
four bills this year
and if I know that by we have
established the house policy
and if I also know that there is a one
of the Senate bills on the same topic
that we'll be leaving Edna shortly to
visit
the Ways and Means Committee
and if I know that that bill will
establish the house policy would I not
press the green button and table this
bill to avoid duplication
the motion before us is the table House
Bill 445 FN this is a division vote if
you're in favor you'll press a green
button of your opposed or press a red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
representative
all members president and opportunity
vote household 10 to stay the vote
378 voting yay six voting a
House Bill 445 is late on the table
the chair recognized the member from
Auburn it was in Osborne for a third
reading motion
thank you Mr Speaker resolved that the
house now adjourned from the early
session that the business of the late
session be in order at the present time
that the reading of bills will be by
title only and resolutions by caption
only and that all bills ordered a third
reading be read a third time by this
resolution then all titles and bills
will be the same as adopted and that
they be passed at the present time when
the house adjourns today it be to meet
at the call of the chair the house will
be in order where still have things to
do
question is on the third wheat emotion
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye those opposed
nay the eyes have it and the motion is
adopted
a house will attend to announcements
chair recognized represent a fool
thank you I'll make this really quick
many of our friends and families their
daughters are attending proms
informal dances
I learned of something that was going on
in downtown Manchester that was captured
by WMUR this past weekend as well and it
has to do with something called Missy's
closet
I don't know the owners I have no
personal connection to them but I think
their vision is awesome
they allow people to effectively borrow
out
dresses for the proms to save people
money
it is a great thing they are doing it is
located
um in the TJ Maxx Plaza on South Willow
Street there's only a couple days it's
open each weekend you can find out
information online but it's a great idea
to help families who can't afford
dresses and whose daughters might want
to attend a prom or a formal dance and
are don't have the means to do so
thank you chair recognize representative
hunt for announcement
thank you very much Mr Speaker first of
all given that it's April 6th I want you
to wish you all a Happy Tartan day
this is our Scottish day normally
historically we have celebrated it but
we'll wait till next year for that event
but even more exciting is that it is not
even 3 30 yet so we might actually beat
the Senate to the auto dealers annual
event in which they invite us this is a
very unusual that we get out so early so
don't want to miss this uh you might
actually get the shrimp because the
Senate won't be there yet so please go
to the uh where are we going it's a
Holiday Inn
be there
chair recognize the clerk thank you Mr
Speaker uh members today we had an
exorbitant amount of paper in our seat
Pockets we have brought up extra
recycling bins that are in the ante room
so please
please on your way out please dispose of
that paper in the recycling bins thank
you
chair recognizes representative McCarter
for unanimous consent
thank you Mr Speaker good afternoon
everybody I know it's been a long day I
won't take too much of your time I know
a lot of you but not all of you my name
is Nikki McCarter and I'm from Belknap
County in Belmont and I'm an alcoholic
I have been one for nearly all of my
adult life with sporadic periods of
sobriety
when I thought about running for office
I wanted to bring a conservative voice
to Concord to represent the constituents
in District 8.
I asked myself lots of questions
how can I make this work with my job my
family my dogs whatever
you all have the same things to juggle
the most important perhaps the only
question I should have asked myself was
how will this affect my sobriety
well it did
and it was a big fail
two weeks ago I acknowledged the very
familiar unforgiving stormy sea I was
swimming in again
I reached out for help and was admitted
to Liberty Health Services in Derry
the staff were very kind competent and
efficient
I left there with a toolbox full of
tools and A Renewed confidence to do the
job I was elected to do
I want to express my sincere apologies
for missing many important pieces of
legislation especially HB 10. I've heard
a lot about that from my constituents
the words of encouragement and prayers
meant a lot so thank you to those who
reached out
to me
gratitude is difficult to maintain when
your life feels full of troubles
I now look every day and find some and
I'm grateful to be here with all of you
today
in closing I'd like to share a little
story about gratitude
a blind boy sat on the steps of a
building with a hat by his feet
he held up a sign which read I am blind
please help
there were only a few coins in the Hat
spare change from folks as they hard
passed
a man was walking by
he took a few coins from his pocket
dropped them in the Hat he then took the
sign he turned it over and wrote some
words put it back in the boy's hand and
walked away
that way everyone who walked by would
see the new words
soon the Hat began to fill up
a lot more people were giving money to
the blind boy
that afternoon the man returned to see
how things were going
the little boy recognized the footsteps
and asked were you the one who changed
my sign this morning what does it say
the man said I only wrote the truth I
said what you said just in a different
way
I wrote today is a beautiful day but I
cannot see it
both signs spoke the truth the first
simply said the boy was blind the second
conveyed to everyone walking by how
grateful they should be
I'm very grateful to be here today and I
see a lot of things that I've been
ignoring for a long time
so if you or someone you know is
struggling with any kind of an addiction
there is a lot of help out there you can
start simply by dialing 2-1-1 which is
what I did
asking for and accepting help is amazing
sobriety is a superpower not a defect
time to take off my mask and put on my
Cape thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
without objection the remarks will be
printed
do you recognizes representative Heath
Howard for unanimous consent
Mr Speaker and honorable Representatives
I understand it we have had a long day
so I will be brief
for those of you who are unaware the
restrict act or United States Senate
Bill 686 is legislation that goes
against New Hampshire's ideals and
violates the first and Fourth Amendment
the bill is focused on tackling the
issue of data theft which is a problem
but this legislation would punish the
individual user instead of punishing the
perpetrator
this is not Justice and it would not it
would only serve authoritarian purposes
Banning people from accessing or
attempting to access data originating
from another country
no matter what country that is it does
not necessarily mean that it is done so
maliciously
the bill fails to provide any sort of
national security or privacy protection
and does not establish any sort of data
right
instead the Secretary of Commerce would
be able to regulate apps like websites
vpns and entire companies just to name a
few
all in closed door meetings with limited
input from the people
Hardware like certain brands of cell
phones or computers would become illegal
and software that people use every day
would become a felonious Act
for example I'm talking about Lenovo
laptops and acts in apps like expressvpn
which would be doubly illegal because it
would allow you to bypass the ban
these are everyday products that you
would not think about twice
and would continue to use if they were
not subject to a ban
enforcement of this policy would allow
officers to inspect search detain seize
or impose temporary denial orders with
respect to items in any form or
conveyances on which it is believed
their items to have been
our being or are imported to into the
United States in violation of this act
or any other applicable federal law
this is an obvious trampling of our
Fourth Amendment right with under uh the
claim that it is necessary for National
Security
the ACLU has voiced its concern over the
First Amendment problems with
implementing this legislation and how
bending apps could silence the public
because quote if the secretary uses this
newfound power to ban apps like Tick
tobs Tick Tock or other communication
platforms without evidence of
overwhelming or imminent harm it would
violate the freedom of expression
I hope you will join me in contacting
Senator Shaheen and Senator Hassan and
voicing your concern over this dangerous
act thank you
before we read the final motion
I just want to say how proud I am of
this body
nobody can remember the last time that
we passed the budget bipartisan as we
have today and I think you all deserve
one hell of a
thank you and for this accomplishment
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
representative Auburn Osborne moves at
the house stand in recess for the
purpose of an introduction of bills and
World build amendments enrolled build
reports vacate motions and receiving
messages are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye as opposed
Navy eyes have it and the motion is
adopted the house is in recess the call
of the chair
okay